and without further ado we are getting
set for what the fans see on their
screen right now that is Jana pom Niazi
versus Levon Aronian speech has
championship with me here is the one and
only Anna Rudolph as we get set to start
things off Anna how excited are you for
this one super excited and I love your
ex and any that nipple Mia she was
perfect I do my best to to try to
pronounce things as they should be
pronounced but let's do our best to
remind the fans of what they're watching
as we head over to our reminder that the
bracket continues and the speeches
championship rages on we already have
Wesley so Sasha Grichuk Hikaru Nakamura
and Sergei karak and having moved on to
the next round today we have Levon
Aronian in the pom me ah she who do you
think is gonna move on Anna
I think 2017 has been the year of
Lebanon Rania I'm expecting to win this
although new partner she is clearly a
blitz and bullet expert I haven't seen
much of LaVon playing online so that is
a handicap for him yeah I have the same
thoughts that I wonder how much LaVon
plays online I feel like Nepal Miyoshi
I've seen him more on our site I'm in
plus as a bullet at least he's been
known as a bullet specialist I wonder
what the fastest time control will bring
and let's remind everybody exactly what
that format is as we speak about the
time controls we start with ninety
minutes of the 5:2 blitz
we move into sixty minutes of three two
and then a half an hour of bullet chess
with chess960 games being mixed in the
players are competing for a ton of
prizes but really the biggest prize at
this point this early in the bracket
challenges just to move on a lot of
money at stake but of course the big
thing is that they want to move on to
the next round and before we move on and
as the games get started here we want to
give a quick shout out to our sponsors
masterclass of course becoming the
headlining sponsor of the 2017 speech s
championship and quick word from them on
everything they can expect everything
fans can expect if they sign up for the
master class the chess series coming out
by Garry Kasparov
[Music]
check chess is a game of unlimited
beauty but it's not just checkstand
attacks you have to be creative
I'm here to share with you my knowledge
of the game of chess but I'm trying to
come up with the comprehensive picture
that will be helpful for you to become a
better chess player and even a better
decision let's cover 25 Kings c2 King f6
can be speaking with seven King
supporting the six King before King
second-guessing boom what lost yes
Quinn takes the knight f5 and it's a
double attack skewer and attraction and
its mate but an amazing mate how can we
prevent this rook from stopping our poll
let's pause stop the video and see you
have time to find this winning
combination
did you see that it's your visuals
weathers really I'm not support no I
don't say that that's that's interesting
so you attack my bishop then you protect
your bishop right so let's go back and
see whether we can improve and what's
the next logical rules
that's about coming up with new ideas
challenging your own excellence to find
your mistakes next time you have to bet
I've been thinking about few ideas that
I never used the one I want to show it's
another sacrifice I'd like sacrifices
and it's one of my favorite obliques so
just let's have a little you can waste
time time is precious
if you don't feel that the game can
leash will create a potential then you
already in the losing side it's not
about winning or losing
and of course at the end of the day it's
about winning I'm Gary Kasparov and this
is my master class
and we are we are ready to go with love
here in garry kasparov talked about his
master class but I love even what I love
even more is Levon Aronian Celtic Jersey
I've been told he's not just a fan of
the Celtics because of the recent Kyrie
Irving trade but a lifelong fan so the
games have started and it is time to
rock one see for is that a surprise
Danny I know I don't know I don't know
they both play the English very often so
I was expecting the English in almost
every game of every second game but my
question would have been to you before
they started if we are going to see
their traditional openings in blitz or
something more offbeat well I think at
this point we would we would think
traditional Livanos Levon is thinking
and hopefully aware that that it is his
move and I assume that I assume that he
is and not just lost in and following
chess TV chat or something and there he
goes and we are off I don't know I mean
I as you said these players play these
players both play the English and they
also both play each other a lot actually
and as they just got done competing at
the st. Louis Sinquefield Cup as well as
the rapid and blitz so pretty big
history with these two going at it and I
think that makes it even more exciting
to have them face off here so what we
see here is an opening that they have
played against each other several times
with both colors and actually the
Sinquefield Cup and say no it's blitz
and rapidly so and the English opening
as well Mitchell it's interesting to see
that they know it's over with both
colors do you remember this rock age 4
by 11 Aronian a distinct foot cup and it
was funny to see that because yang was
aware of that move as an idea for white
because he plays it as white as well so
I'm curious to see who out prepares who
since they notice opening so well yeah I
agree and of course that that game at
this
cup was was super impressive by the
Vaughn and a great way for him to get
started there with a big win is white
and this line III wonder the players
have been thinking a little bit out of
the opening here makes me wonder what
exactly they're trying to remember Black
has I think black is equalized here in
the opening a pretty nice queen in the
center I wonder if this Queen is about
to head over to h5 and maybe start some
sort of attack on the Kings side things
like 94 okay but he decides he's not
super thrilled about the idea of this
rook sitting on the diagonal to this
bishop on a three so plate why you said
I like the idea of Queen h5 94 it's
always good to threaten me team one
never never not a fun idea to threaten
made him one I agree so alright well
what do you think about this position
who do we think is better here we've got
efore which means that I think one of
the biggest things black has to worry
about right now is the strike of f4
coming and and whether that leads to
some sort of attack in the center with
white getting a big palm storm but black
is ready h5 was a good idea so he steps
out of f4 and prepares 9g for the other
question is this e5 Knight which could
be a very strong piece or a very awkward
piece since it doesn't have many jumps
right well here we go LaVon is all in on
the attack Bishop h3 gives up the b7
pawn nepo decides I'm not gonna take it
place five but don't be surprised if we
see you know I move like Knight g4 at
some point this b7 pawn will be falling
maybe not right away due to things like
93 coming and we can see on the board
that's exactly the kind of line that
we're gonna be getting into here so
Knight e3 fork is of course the clear
threat after capture on h3 Queen takes
Knight e3 is still a threat but now
after rupee one what shall black do the
b7 pawn is still hanging and there's no
meat on h2
simply a rube d8 I like that move
because after Knight takes b7 I think he
wants to go Ruby 3 and you sometimes
have the idea of sacrificing on g3 yeah
it looks like we may get something like
that right now
the the knight on c5 I wonder if it'll
had to be seven or come back to e4 and
perhaps head over to to g5 nineteen
forest for sure safer but do we know
napalm yeah she for playing it safe not
really not really right right up there
with reputation goes our e6 yeah because
he wants to take the initiative my god
he's six and after F takes 96 it's
looking good for white the question is
does black have to take this form right
I mean black has the the bind over on
the you know on the h2 square and and
that ties the Queen down to always being
worried about potential threats of
checkmate but but white is saying I
don't care about the ur your queen and
your queen on a senior night on g4
because if he can open up the e-file
he'll get plenty of his own attacking
chances here LaVon is LaVon is gonna do
a think and and one of the things that
we have to point out always is we we
first start to notice the separation on
the clock right now palm neo she is up
about a minute and a half over LaVon or
owning in which we'll see if that
continues to be something that repeats
during the five minute portion yeah
that's a huge time advantage the
position is very complicated after f5
like and allows this easy exposed to
stay alive that's a postponed after each
seven if white can push e7 it will be a
very dangerous possible and the question
is will black have enough counter play
with something like route d3 yeah rook
t3 until five so he's trying to chase it
away and then play for this idea but I'm
not sure that blacks attack is that
strong here it looks like white has
everything under control
yeah and I don't see a way to remove the
night from from c5 although if b6 is
played next word exactly does then I go
yeah that's the problem of the c5 Knight
if you don't take the b7 point now now
he went for it yeah well most players
are me b3 but then I see five
back
I think young is doing fine here unless
there will be some crazy tactics that
could work after lube d3 now the knight
comes back to c5
I don't think route 63 works with the
rookie and the Queen on the second rank
protecting everything Knight III on the
other hand is a threat so he shuts the
part of that fork yeah actually that's a
problem he cannot go 95 because Knight
e3 is a stronger threat yes sorry I'm
focused on focused on the position like
you said okay Bishop c5 is a strong move
there that stops this idea of 93 and now
we've got 7 it's kind of trapped if
black had time for a Ruby eight right
simple I know got to go the problem is
this e six pawn is such a dangerous
threat the moment a growth moves we have
we have problems so okay is there any
way for black to continue the attack
that would be the question here without
having to without having to let the e
pawn run wild and here Knight takes h2
the threat of rook takes g3 check
following after king h1 though the main
idea is okay so the rook would hang
forces white to block and and Levon
Aronian is all in on this piece
sacrifice here
starting to take on g2 and win the Queen
major up g6 right rook h6 is a big
threat at first glance we got to love
this sacrifice right the knight Knight
has already gotten a couple pawns for
the piece in fact three now that the e6
pawn is fault so the question is that
the endgame is forced and black doesn't
get to have a checkmate attack does he
have enough probably not so LaVon says
I'm not interested in the end game and
this renews the threat of rook to g6
here which as you said would be pinning
the Queen to the King so this is winning
for black since she's got so many
threats four points for the peace and
the b7 Knight is not coming out anyway
this looks like a crushing victory from
a position oh maybe I was too early too
the victory the Queen d5 pin is annoying
so now maybe he has to go for a
perpetual the rook h6 trick threat is
obviously stopped now with the Queen
pinning the rook but but but yeah there
seems to be no way to unpin the rook
LaVon just get it did a little head Bob
there I think that might be the I agree
this is a draw head Bob and indeed
that's what happens nothing like the I
agree this is a draw head Bob and
players rematching each other and game
one is in the books we have a peaceful
result to start but not due to lack of
trying right a lot of fireworks there
with that peace sacrifice by LaVon I
think first round game we did not see
this in every match usually players
started out more slowly more solid but
they are going for it yeah well that's
exciting alright so what do we have here
we have a varus off this is right up my
alley white playing something a little
bit offbeat and here comes the h1 again
he's probably reminding nepo that you
know I beat you with an aggressive H
pawn push not too long ago maybe these
nightmares are still there
I remember eleventh interview with a mic
test that counts Mike and Mike asked him
like didn't you say that you don't play
Bishop f4 anymore because you're
disgusted by this Bishop f4 and he said
not in classical chess in rapid and
blitz it works it works
okay well now he's going back to fish
before again he's that so one of the
things here everybody with this knight
on b5 it's a little bit unorthodox but
the point is that as weird as this this
looks the knight on b5 is actually
really a thorn for black and and it
forces black to put this Knight on a6 to
make sure that the c7 square isn't
access so this is not the normal
position you see every day and not the
one you normally would would encourage
your beginning chef students to play
with white completely neglecting the
King and going all-in on an attack and
is he gonna sacrifice the exchange if
nepo plays Knight takes h5 I wonder if
he's just gonna yeah that looks like the
kind of move that Levin would love to
make yeah that could be that could be a
ton of fun and
I've just seemed like saying that he
also called Levin playing Bishop f4 in
book house even in pack house well let's
let's check out the analysis if he
actually does take and after captures
and queen takes what exactly is lavon's
plan he's down the exchange but there's
attacking chances things like the bishop
coming to d3 h7 is falling so
interesting stuff Neko plays Bishop d7
and decides I'm not interested in
capturing on h5 and LaVon will take the
h-file since now the rook is is free to
roam and maybe there's even ideas like
Bishop h6 I I have a hard time not
liking white in these positions but
that's because I've always been biased
toward completely dubious attacks so I'm
not I'm not sure if LaVon really has a
good enough attack but when I see the
rook open I see this pony hopping into
e5 I start to think that LaVon came to
play blitz today this is a blitz opening
with all kinds of crazy stuff on the
board he did prepare specially for the
blitz it seems and I agree with you that
this position looks so nice for white
even strategically speaking you have
these beautiful if I spot for the night
as you mentioned even the pole structure
is better for white all he needs to do
is develop some pieces so one of the
questions here for Black is always do I
want to play a move like c4 and these
weird varus sauce as much as that's not
a move positional you like it cuts off
the bishop and therefore for black kind
of renews the threat of capturing on b5
black has a problem here and that it's
really hard to untie the Queen side and
and and so you've got the Queen
committed you've got the knight
committed on a6 and and that's one of
the things that makes this varus off
such a tricky opening to play against
for black is finding a way to break
through after this pony has established
itself on b5 because you really want to
play pawn to a6 but you just can't the
Knights in the way I'm surprised that he
didn't want to prevent a5 because I was
worried about this a5 push for White's
where do you go with the black Queen
yeah that's it that's a strong idea and
in fact I don't know why let's back up
and see he didn't do that he played
Bishop a5 but what would have happened
on a5 Queen moves and just taking the a
7-point not sure but I felt like the
Queen was running out of space right
well I move the you know with the Queen
back on D
maybe you know maybe someone is is
pretty crap so mm-hmm
okay interesting LaVon doesn't go for
that instead Bishop e5 and now we see
the move I was suggesting NEPA Bob was
thinking about which is c4 again
everybody that cuts off the bishops
protection of the night and it's
critical for black to do something
because if he just sits there you know
we've already seen LaVon put the bishop
on e5 he's opened up the H file he's
building up for an attack on the
kingside so so this is exactly why Nikko
has to do something quickly on the Queen
side and there's known no more a five
that's the only thing I don't like after
c-4 like prevented a5 and there's no
direct attack at the moment also the c-4
pump which takes away the d3 square from
the bishop so it's not that easy to
develop wise pieces yeah now we see b3
this is this is a nice idea this is
something you normally want to try to do
when your opponent has expanded in the
center like this but variations we have
to start calculating or like Bishop
takes b5 it takes b5 Queen takes takes
c4 takes and at the end it seems like
black is holding on to the pawn but but
at a cost right White has the bishop
pair and the light squares are
potentially very weak so I'm not sure if
we're gonna see nepo take on on d5 with
the bishop what do you think in him I
think he will have to go for something
if he allows simply not capture on b3
for instance he takes Queen takes or
doesn't do anything about the c4 point I
think if I feel be just better so I
would go for some pawn grab as black at
least you have a pawn up and then you
try to defend yourself and I think debo
agrees with you so good call he goes for
that line kind of agrees that I can't
just sit on it and we're getting that
exact position we just analyzed and
we'll see how LaVon wants to prove his
compensation I feel like this is a
position that's that's tricky for black
still despite the fact that he's hold on
to the pawn but that being said what's
White's concrete plan I mean am I gonna
play Bishop b2 and castles short and
give up on my goals of the h-file that
would seem weird
so what else what else am I supposed to
do here is white it's not easy
that's the problem with this c4 pawn it
takes away
that's square that you needed on d3 of
course this position should be at least
unclear because what has the pair of
bishops and very active pieces but it
doesn't look like he's got a clear
direct way of attacking blacks King on
g8
yeah I agree both players are showing us
a little bit of their of how they're
gonna be on camera
niebo having a little bit of a head bob
there he's got some music going I think
both these players plan to listen to
music they asked me that in the pregame
show and confirmed that neither one of
them had a problem listening to music so
we don't have a problem with it
Nepos got the Screamers chair ana right
I mean he's a big donor for a lot of
people know that nepo nepo loves himself
some esports place easy as a gamer and
that's a chair that is that chair behind
a pom neo she is made for hours and
hours of sitting down so I think we
wouldn't need one Danny I need one I
don't know the reason I don't have a
chair where the back is exactly because
the the fact that if I had a chair with
the back it would it would be in the way
of our you'll be able to see a big old
big old chair behind mine I actually I
fear for you I'm sitting on a very
uncomfortable stool just so that you
can't see the back of that shelf
that's the the life of a host but
speaking of hosting what are we hosting
this is the 2017 speech Chess
Championship if you're just joining us
brought to you by masterclass we are
your hosts Danny wrench and Anna Rudolph
and we are here for the next several
hours to be analyzing games between
these two super grandmasters the winner
of this match will move on in the in our
in our tournament in the bracket and be
joining the winner of this match will be
playing Sergey Karjakin
so they already know who waits for the
man and Sergey Cory I can just just put
on quite an impressive showing at the
st. Louis wrap and blitz not not quite
as good overall as Levon Aronian but in
the blitz he was he was more than
impressive so this is interesting stuff
and should be fun to see which of these
two players moves on let's go back to
the board here and see what they're
thinking about Levon has gotten his
Queen out to g4 that 1892 he runs and
then Queen g4 for sure some directs
Fred's already Queen e6 and capturing on
g6 so that has to be extremely careful
we the rook would be hanging on c8 if
you play a recap seven so you either
need to protect this see a truck or
somehow protect the e6 square with I
don't know which Mel Brooks e6 looks a
bit weird because Daniel Queen of D 5
will be once again awkward so he
captures e5 and now after Queen e6 check
is y can be able pickup the bishop with
check looks like he will LaVon speeding
up sensing a little bit of his of his
chance to strike here looking at the
clock and we have two minutes for
Aronian and already down to 30 seconds
remember everybody the time control is
five two blitz you can see that on your
screen now what does that mean it means
five minutes total but you gain two
seconds with every move that's an
increment and a very common time control
so if the players are down on time don't
think that he's just gonna lose on time
right now palm Miyoshi as you can see
only has 33 seconds but but the position
is still unclear what's happening on 94
herein is that a move that Michael wind
also pawn to e4 I think those are the
two candidate most LaVon is calculating
he's actually singing or either
calculating out loud but his lips are
moving
yeah he's he's calculating out loud in
his head and let's let's do some
calculating ourselves so what happens in
this position after E for with the pawn
the knight is pinned to the Queen
everybody that's that's Anna's point
yeah and then Queen takes East 7-7
Architects h7 is possible that oh but g4
might be even stronger of course because
g5 is a huge threat and you're not
exchanging pieces yeah interesting and
again everybody this night is still kind
of pinned if you take here to protect
the Queen any other night move and lose
the Queen we're gonna get exactly that
kind of line Anna was just talking about
what the rook coming in so nepo says I'm
not interested in that puts the King on
GH but I get the feeling the worst has
not been had yet I think LaVon is gonna
continue to attack you here comes Queen
e6 check yep h3 is possible as well so
this Bishop will be active finally right
well the rook on c8 is hanging right I
mean that's a rook I mean what yeah I
mean there he goes he grabs it okay
that's a rook as a rook I'm not sure if
Nebo just missed
or or if he's hoping that queen bee two
turns into some kind of surprising
counter-attack here he's gonna get this
is just desperate seems right in fact
even Queen takes c4 I was just gonna say
that's probably resigned time no he
doesn't want it yet nepo trying to get
some of his nerves out of the way
perhaps and play this one on sometimes
it's good when you lose a game early in
in a match like this I mean having done
a lot of them I think the players like
to play it out a little bit you're
nervous right and you know there's gonna
be a long a long series of games over
the next few hours so maybe play it out
a little bit and don't just resign
despite the fact that in a classical
game I think the pom neo she would have
resigned on Queen take c8 yeah now they
could repeat Mughals but I guess for the
rock up that's out question yeah not
lavon's idea maybe now he'll just take a
six ok now he plays Bishop d3 I'm
surprised he didn't just go trade I mean
you're up a Brook right go trade pieces
you could have just played Bishop takes
a six all right but but LaVon wants more
Queen takes p7 I think nepo has to play
the move Knight a six to b4 here no he
decides to play a defensive retreat of
the night but okay it's just a matter of
coordinating right I guess the big issue
here for LaVon Anna is that he can't
just play King he to it cuz there's
Knight c3 in some positions but maybe
now he plays King e to rook see one
first and then once he can move the King
that's just a great moment to resign
right as soon as this King gets out of
the pin by the Queen and and the pieces
are free to start jumping to life I
think I think I think we'll see the
towel thrown in wait a second okay no he
does did not blunder that he's just
coordinating still though nipple playing
it on with no time on the clock but you
know now the condom board and no rook on
the board down a ruck and he's playing
it on let's see exactly what what the
players facial expressions tell us I
think nip oh yeah as we said he he's
just kind of just trying to play it out
a little bit longer I don't know that he
really thinks he can win this although
look at the clock right LaVon continues
to get himself down on time which is
just a little surprising right it is
surprising and they are playing with a
different time control than it was
insane
so maybe they are expecting the delay
system and its increment right yes
that's quite possible yes funny dad the
king can still not go any safer than
anyone but all right this is just just a
matter of time right I mean yeah at this
point I'm surprised the game has lasted
as long as it did but you got to give
NEPA credit for keeping things tricky
and maybe it's a sign of a bond that
just because you get a winning position
doesn't mean he's gonna throw in the
towel okay but there you go I think that
was that was that was a smile and
alright a little bit of tricks there
before I throw in the towel but with
that we have our first we have our first
victory decisive game in the match and
it is a win from the bottom row naeun as
we can see he jumps out to a one and a
half half lead in the score so what do
we have here as far as c-45 set up it's
usually 11 plays against the English and
they are playing extremely fast of
course as we mentioned they are experts
of the English opening with of colours
I'm not expecting any opening novelty
but it's actually interesting to see
what variation they choose for blitz
because of course they know the theory
so well but which position is more
tricky
they might favor those variations even
if they are dubious yeah I agree I mean
the thing about blitz says a lot of
people say it's sometimes much more
important to be comfortable with the
position than whether you believe the
position is theoretically the best your
ability to play quickly find the plan
and know intuitively what's going on
really important and you know but I tend
to like black again here I feel like
LaVon has has done well in this English
this night coming to d4 now he's gonna
take back with the pawn most likely
everybody even though that blocks the
bishop because you normally want to see
the rook and the bishop come together on
e - that's called the Mirko hop
structure everybody where the knight
hops into d4 and it opens up some
pressure so you can make a mental note
of that and learn from these two and I
and I like flex position in these in
these English's again maybe I'm biased
the fact that I play these positions has
not as white but okay so now black has
to deal with the b7 pawn he does that
with c6 Bishop because I'm b6 it's a
very poor piece you would need another
diagonal for that Bishop right yeah
you're right and that's definitely the
drawback to taking on d4 with the pawn
as you've sort of self self imprisoned
but black hopes to sort of unwind long
term and have the bishop pair right yeah
I'm getting some info from Mike thanks
Mike for helping us out all the time
with all these stats and infos that
re-implanted Bishop b4 this variation
and not d5 in st. Louis they play the
four Knights variation but not to be d5
good to know we'll back up to that
position just to show the fans exactly
what Mike is saying the move Bishop to
b4 was played in st. Louis by Levon
Aronian against this very same opponent
right and and again these two guys have
played each other a lot and so it'll be
interesting to see the theory I think I
think even if you and I are not able to
keep up with all the theory during the
match this might be one of the most
interesting post speech has championship
news reports as we show how many times
these guys have played these positions
so if you're an English player or
curious on an approach to play against
the English these two guys might be
about to instruct us on on variations
that they really like that's true that
that is very instructive to see of
course by these two how about this
position you are an expert of dispersion
as black some experiment
I like black side I mean rookie seven is
played with exactly the plan we talked
about right I mean here black should
back up the bishop likely to h5 and then
prepare to double on the e-file and and
continue to be stubborn and the approach
right the whole idea of black bringing
the knight to d4 was exactly so that
this trade would happen and that the
e-file would open up but okay right as I
say that I'm a little surprised he
brings the bishop to e6 rather than h5
and what is his intention now I think
that I think that he may he may not
really be super worried about Knight
takes c6 yeah and just play rook e8 with
the idea that if Y trades on e6 we're
still in a position where I think black
is kind of kind of in control of
probably getting closer and closer to an
equal result
though with with two opposite code
bishops on the board it just suggests to
us that the light squares and the dark
squares will will lead us to lead us to
an equal endgame but but we'll see yes I
was also surprised by this Bishop e6
move but it seems like on the study that
the c5 Knight was stronger than any of
his bishops yeah interesting and b5 is a
nice move right and the the main thing
is that you want to open up the
diagonals so that your so this your
bishop here on on g2 is is right where
it needs to be and hitting the b7 square
LaVon
takes in place c5 interesting this is
getting close I feel like the the Queen
side is becoming more of a problem for
black because now this Bishop on b6 has
a hard time moving without maybe White's
rook coming into a7 and this pawn on b7
becoming a bit of a target so I feel
like depot has has gotten through the
worst of that that middle game and I and
I start to like the way white has
unwound here this bishop on f3 anna does
an excellent job of guarding the biggest
weakness in this structure which is the
e2 pawn so I just I feel like white is
white is doing just fine here I also
like white and it happens all the time
with opposite colored bishops that if
you are active and if you are attacking
then you're basically a piece of because
the other bishop cannot defend the
squares that you are attacking so the b7
pawn is a problem and the question is
whether white can actually enter the
position doubling rooks and rook e8
yeah I agree and here comes four okay
four I like this move again for neat boy
I feel like he's he's worked his way out
of it and he also did so anna by playing
pretty quickly on the clock I mean he's
got he's got more than four minutes
still in this position and just just
about doubling the time of his opponent
so all these games that we have seen
except the game he lost right I mean
last game he was under time pressure and
we always talk about that with players
at this level that pretty much the
person who's up on time is usually also
the person who has a better position or
at least has had a better I feel for the
position although that you know
there are some exceptions to that okay
well interesting now as far as total
time remind everybody we have an hour
left total for five minutes chefs so the
party is just getting started
and we will see a lot more instructive
games the five-minute portion my
personal favorite doing a lot of these
matches because it's the time where we
actually get to kind of enjoy you know
the most high-quality chests normally
although we've seen some pretty high
quality three minutes yes - but alright
nepo is is really unwinding here now and
I mean as you can see he's got the he's
got the rooks
on the a file the e to pawn has become a
complete non-issue with this Bishop
taking care of defense and uh and I like
right now I mean white have winning
chances I don't know I mean how do we
infiltrate right you can't come to the
a7 square as long as the bishops here
and black doesn't want to go to e2 as
long as the bishops here so so what's
the plan how do we wiggle in here for
white here here comes the Queen trying
to come to d5 yeah I guess what young is
doing is just to improve his position
little by little even if it's not a
winning position it's much more
comfortable for him and he can do
whatever he wants he can go back and
forth with his pieces black always has
to be careful with all the threats like
rook e8 Queen d5 he has to protect all
those squares so on the long run this is
very unpleasant for black even if it's
like a 0-0 position for an engine of
course but it could be it could be that
it's close to equal by the way I hear
from man that you played a similar
position against Commodore with a cone
exchange on c5 I played a similar
position against komodo with a pawn
exchange on on see I don't even remember
what I played against Komodo I've
already blacked it out because it was a
it was a brutal it was it was a it was a
brutal it was a brutal man no I mean I
played I started out playing well this
was a man versus machine match that took
place this week so if you're into that
kind of thing humans humans versus
machines then then go ahead and check
out my games against come over this week
but it was tough all right what do we
have here we got this it takes age five
age five already so after Queen g5 it
was a double attack
threatening the ricany seven and Bishop
takes H five this is how you win this
position you go back and forth threaten
here and there and in the end blank
blunders yeah and especially because of
the time pressure factor right I mean
the thing is sometimes people I think
lose sight of the fact that you play on
an equal position just because it's
equal doesn't mean it's a draw and if
you play on an equal position and you're
up on time maybe eventually somebody
blunders this is a really nice
combination here Rumph d5 Bishop g4 this
is how you saved a piece and now it's
gone up yeah that's exactly what we have
here let's slide over to the analysis
board so that we can show everybody
exactly what happened there we had this
position where when the bishop took on
h5 everybody this pawn on g6 was pinned
to the King and I think LaVon missed it
because you would think this pawn is
untouchable due to rook d5 which is a
skewer but Nebo has this little
Intermezzo tempo and if if LaVon had
captured g5 nipa would have taken he six
and at the end of a line like this he's
not only up a pawn but in exchange so if
that all happened too fast for you that
was how Neto got away with stealing that
pawn and now now he's really in the
driver's seat Anna with a big advantage
on the clock and just up a clear pollen
on the board so I think we're about to
see a level score in this match
yeah also the rook is now in the
background if he could double rooks on
the background then the king is in
trouble on g7 so you will have to play
rook e8 as black yeah rook rook to see
it's a nice move here comes the other
rook into a8 have a hard time how he
trains me because he wants the seventh
rank with the rook perhaps you probably
now he wants that after b6 the seventh
rank is just beautiful for that yeah
yeah okay so that makes sense here he
comes into the seventh rank and I assume
moves like h5 and Queen g5 are gonna
follow here not exactly sure what order
but at some point White's gonna start
launching an attack on the Kings side
and I think LaVon is going down in this
game yeah now this pin h5 is there if
you take Queen g5 check I believe and
okay he didn't take well here comes h6
though right if h6 now the f7 point
falls so I wonder I wonder if LaVon
quickly played bishop
but Nepos scoots up in his chair as we
can see and I'm gonna guess that he's
calculating whether h6 King g8 h7 kind
of works he decides no yeah it looked
like a really interesting way to keep
the attack going but NEPA NEPA being
smart from a practical perspective Ana
he's not even going for the most obvious
forcing lines right he's sitting on the
position and when you have a big
advantage on the clock everybody it's
it's really you know that shows patience
and discipline to just kind of sit tight
and and let your opponents suffer with
no time on the clock
yeah but I'm wondering now if he was
maybe wanting to be too smart
this Queen edge one move allowing group
age eight yeah LaVon goes and gets that
pawn back and okay it's still feels like
white is white is potentially doing well
here with this wide open King but but I
agree with you where's the concrete move
here now for for white I think he was
not careful enough so it was it was good
not to go for like the most concrete
variation with three minutes on the
clock against ten seconds but he had to
be careful about most high Queen age one
and now black has come they're like yeah
I agree
no you're right I mean it's a that's the
counter play you got to be careful about
but it still looks like an obstacle drip
ending with no time on the clock you can
see the bond really getting really
getting down to it gaining a couple
seconds back there but he's literally
living off the increment right now and
one tricky move might make him think and
just lose how doesn't even want to
continue the attack there's interesting
moves like f4 here yeah and he goes for
it I like it yeah the point everybody is
he black couldn't take it because in the
end white would have been end up winning
a piece it's a very strong move in a
very nice game 33 everybody because
after King to g7 we would see Queen
takes h8 mate so just a fantastic that
was a fantastic attack by nepo and even
if it wasn't always technically perfect
he kept LaVon under pressure order time
pressure and and we haven't even matched
right yeah yeah it was surprising I
don't think that Queen age one was the
best move as you said but it was working
because LaVon was just so short on time
he could
the best moves and here goes the H phone
again here we go again
another day another varus off another
crazy H pawn by Aronian against nepo and
nepo kind of shrugs off there and
although not exactly sure what he's
thinking now Aronian takes on c5 this is
just becoming a very unorthodox kind of
position I mean this is weird to see
white neglect developing moves you know
in exchange for this sort of aggressive
pawn push then he takes a pawn and black
doesn't even take it back he sacrifices
another I feel like this is just this is
getting beyond me I don't know what's
going on here but I know it's I know
this is probably not the best opening
for either side but both sides trying to
reach kind of a practical position where
they can get good blitz tactics I guess
they are playing for the audience and
yeah they are very generally our dear
audience going for the most spectacular
and most exciting positions no boring
chests today no boring chests today and
yeah Levon again I saw a couple comments
about that yeah he is wearing a Celtics
jersey I don't I don't know if it's an
urban Jersey if it's already on the
market for those of you who are NBA fans
and followed the blockbuster trade there
but he did tell me he was a Celtics fan
forever even before the Erving trade so
but we'll check we'll have snap boy
check on whether he can confirm whether
LaVon is really a Celtics fan or not and
see see but all right LaVon takes the
second Pont and here comes Queen takes
b6 and the B to Pont is officially under
fire and watch out for tactics whenever
you have a file and a diagonal pointing
to the same spot yes so sacrificing
material as black for developments you
see that King me one still struggling to
develop right I like blacks chances as
long as you can keep this initiative
going yeah black is down a pawn right if
you do the math everybody you've got six
pawns for white versus five pawns for
black but as Anna said this King is
still on e1 and you've already exposed
the H file so is this King gonna Castle
you know if he doesn't do it quickly is
is is nepo about to play d4 here d4
looks like a really interesting move
that's a critical move for sure yes I
like this because everybody the point is
if takes then obviously you're blowing
things open and if you take on c6 too
go win the d4 pawn well the problem is
in the end of that line black has g2 so
I'm quickly calculating whether d4 is a
move here for nepo and III I really like
this idea especially given that from a
practical perspective Anna you know we
want to open the centre as long as white
has a king sitting over here on e1 right
very true so d4 if that moves danyoung
will for sure go for it he's calculating
look at that posture he is very much
focused yeah leaning in and trying to
calculate D for I I think that you know
of course in d4 also everybody the g4
bit the g4 piece was hanging and in the
end he decided he didn't want to go for
lines like that but don't be surprised
if we still see a d4 shot coming ok 94
that's also super nice look at this the
F file and the knight are hitting f2 the
e5 Knight is now officially under fire
because 94 unleashed
two attackers to hit that square and
again III like nepo here I don't know
that lavon's alter a crazy varus off
approach here h4 then taking on c5 even
as a varus off player I felt like this
was a really weird way for white to play
I don't like where this Kings going yeah
I do like black in this position I'm
normally not a person that likes
sacrificing material but with the King
anyone I think this is something that
you should definitely go for there you
go if we have an on board for
sacrificing material we know this is
probably pretty good for black lifetime
right and he so he has to Castle because
of the f2 hanging Levon is leaning back
in his chair stretching things out are
we gonna see a 5 here 5 certainly seems
like a move strike in the center
although now that the king is castled
suddenly we start to we start to notice
you know the pollens over here right the
c2 b2 a2 pawns so you know the position
remains dynamic and I still like black
chances and I still kind of like a 5 and
d4 to keep opening the position but but
but white does have a lot of pawns let's
not forget about that
I like blacks chances I'm not sure
though which way shall he continue
because both b5 and attempting he 5 he
started with he goes forward which I
likened but now rook d7 so apparently he
decides he wants to prepare d4 by the
way Mike is correcting us that this is
not the virus or since the bish I went
to f4 this is called the Java pre attack
actually it is a Bishop f4 veresov okay
but Baba plays it more than anybody I
don't know that he's officially earned
the right that it's named after him yet
though I think we should name an opening
after Joe Baba and those I wouldn't be
opposed to it I agree and I I do looked
at your Baba's games but but okay II see
oh it is pretty sure fish before and I
see three still of airsoft so anyway but
yeah here comes nice c5 he removes he
doesn't want the trade and it's still
you know you're gonna see d4 but the
imbalance here everybody's gonna be you
know you look at a position where black
clearly has a nice control over the
center his pieces are a little more
coordinated white white kind of spread
out obviously this Bishop on a to sort
of awkwardly blocked but when you're
looking at a position like this
especially in blitz if black doesn't
keep that bind and keep these pieces
stuck or or find some way to convert on
it by I don't know whether that's
opening the center or some other plan
then in the long run you know white has
these these pawns here you know so this
is this is a big deal as far as whether
black can get something before White's
material advantage it gets going okay
you finally get sneak or I've wanted
that yeah I was just going to say that
whites minor pitted on g3 and h2 are
very poorly placed not coordinating so
anything that black can do he shall do
immediately before white has time to
reorganize pieces yeah he gets t4 and
and Nipah seems still seems to be
confident just given his his body
posture I think LaVon may be a little
more nervous I also I'm gonna have to
talk to him about whatever that is in
his house hanging from his ceiling that
is the weirdest looking chandelier look
at that behind his upper right shoulder
and that is the weirdest looking
chandelier I've ever seen and I hope
it's I hope it's used for light and not
some sort of medieval torture device so
all right the game continues we get 94
I like my day for because if you push
the people and then the c3 square will
be week forever and that's what's
happening that's what's gonna happen yet
and the c2 point is a vac backward porn
also a potential target my c3 now yeah
then I relocates itself to e3 I love
this idea heading towards East we are f4
as well yeah and the seat of bone is
annoyingly weak why the d4 corn is very
well protected by the g7 bishop what
nice move by LaVon I'm surprised we
didn't see an immediate exchange sac but
I guess it's cuz he wanted to guard c2 I
was thinking I wonder if he might just
chop chop and take and play down the
exchange but I think at the end of that
line there's queen take c2 and he wasn't
interested but don't be surprised if we
see LaVon take an opportunity to do one
or two things and I actually sack the
exchange but I'm also just seeing some
idea like let's say a random move white
maybe has c4 with the pawn a really nice
expansion versus black the same that
even though this Knight looks beautiful
on e3 the drawback is that you cannot
take with this default pawn on safety
yeah so let's keep an eye on that
everybody LaVon now feeling a little
more confident and and nepo zooming in
okay h5 I like both c4 and from a
practical perspective I hate this night
so if I really have to I'd like to
consider taking but I don't know that I
have to and and I am I like this idea of
c4 to eliminate myself from having this
week backward pawn and expose as you
said that this pawn cannot capture
without leaving the night hanging ok
Queen d3 I add the game is getting more
unclear right we're seeing we're seeing
a live on unwind and the fact that he's
up a pawn he's got this knight on e4
there's squares like g5 and d6 feeling a
little bit more confident this is gonna
be a wild finish but I'm almost equal
Jack for the first time in the match
yeah first time in the match we've seen
H Ford instructive play buying upon
miasha's value getting some more space
on the kingside and you don't allow
bishop g3 and such much so you take
control of the although squares and I
think if Depot has the way his way he
might even rush h3 right if that him he
can undermine the g2 pawn here comes
rook takes f3 in and all of a sudden we
are breaking through with gusto on the
Kings side I wonder if nepo is thinking
about this right now he sort of leans
back and I think there's obviously a ton
to calculate right Anna at age 3 of
course you don't have to take if you're
white and allowed ro takes f3 you could
also take on e3 and maybe that's exactly
why he he decided to take on c4 first
and then play h3 so this idea is on the
board and I think black is gonna get
some kind of attack here will it be
enough it looks very promising for sure
rookie 4 it's a good move it locks the
diagonal of the Queen but still this
position is very sharp Bishop e5 it's a
good idea to trade pieces as many as you
can you're in danger
he's trying to eliminate eliminate the
pressure and then maybe he'll have me up
a few pawns in the endgame
as far as time goes we were only four
games into the match and we only have 45
minutes left I'm curious what stat boy
mr. Feeley master my client can come up
with us come up for us on that I don't
know offhand what the least amount of
games played in a five-minute portion is
Anna but I bet he can find us the answer
because that's the kind of stuff he
loves to do but this is only four games
over a 45 minute period that just it
seems slow to me but maybe I'm wrong it
does seem slow and even if we recall
this game they're young was that rook
down he did not resign for like 20 moves
so you can go those games longer all
right well what do we have here we've
got the Queen coming to d4 with Czech
and I'm I just feel more and more like
LaVon has turned this game around turn
to TV sure a whole lot of pawns on the
Queen side and the question is will f3
and G to break through for black or will
white find some way to maybe even
simplify trade some queens and go on to
maybe a winning reckoning yeah now what
is officially two pawns up although
those CC phones are not very appealing
but you can count it as one point up at
least I expect rosy for here oh ok and I
expect to be wrong as usual no problem
with that rook rook h5 I'm surprised we
didn't see Brooke g4 but maybe there was
some rope takes f3 trick that I was I
don't know
here comes the king - eat - I think I
think from our own Ian's perspective
he knows the king is never gonna be safe
anyway maybe the king will actually be
safer if he brings it to the center and
if he has a chance to counter-attack
with your key seven if he has a chance I
expect him to try to treat Queens ah
nepo not happy with that as we go back
to the analysis here nip oh we missed a
moment on camera but obviously you and I
could see a nahi NEPA was not happy with
that move everybody and let's stay
zoomed in on these players to see what
kind of emotions we might be able to
catch on camera Levon is slowly shifting
out of my camera capture as we know it's
like the running practical joke that all
these players have with me is we spent
so much time to get him on camera and
then and then as soon as the game
started we can no longer see their faces
of course you've got some stats already
by Mike the lowest amount of games in
the final portion was played last year
by grace shook and Aronian six games
only
okay well Aronian once again involved in
a potential lowest number of games maybe
we'll see although I guess if they're
already on their fourth game maybe my 45
minutes I would imagine they'll get more
than two games so we'll see I you know
but but look at LaVon he's really played
well in this one right and now we look
at the clock though it's going to be a
time scramble and that's that that
always leads us to the potential chance
for some blunders like that yes it does
look no but no it's not a blunder wow
he's calculated so well if black had
played queen takes up guy was like oh my
god he blundered Aronian had calculated
so well to know he would have been able
to get back his rook and being a winning
Queen upon ending so but is this good
anyway it looks like okay he's not
getting a perpetual because of King
before but still
yeah Queen a1 Shaq is met by pawn to c3
blocking the check and now here comes
Queen takes g6 mm-hmm yeah he had
everything under control it seems yeah
really really well calculated and gutsy
approach there by Aronian right I mean
he walks his King into the middle of the
fire zone and he continues to do it here
comes the king to c5 and he's gonna play
rook d4
I bet yep and their plane moves faster
than we can predict them now shaking his
head of course this is not how he wanted
the game to turn out he was better after
the opening for sure for sure this was
not the best vert of Soph bye-bye LaVon
working his way back into a position to
offer a queen trade but don't be
surprised if you get your King in
trouble here and now LaVon no this could
this could end up very badly he may have
seized a perpetual or he may be looking
for LaVon to step on a land line and get
himself mated Oh or maybe they blow it
he allows King before and now this King
has a race back love nepo looks to the
corner he knows he's messed up the
perpetual
the King comes to d3 and now Queen a3
check would have been met by c3 blocking
to check everybody suddenly the script
is flipped and LaVon is on the check
attack and I think he's gonna lead to a
mate very quickly here coming up in a
few moves Oh No instead maybe just a
Queen trade is is good enough though he
might even be able to force himself into
a crossfire check that forces a Queen
trade I'm sure he's gonna be looking for
that now he's trying to look for a way
to give a check everybody a crossfire
check we call it where you check here
and when the King moves you check and
trade Queens but ok even if he can't
find it Aronian it's gonna go on to win
this one just too many pawns and and Wow
quite that was quite the game right it
was and that moment when she finally had
a chance to give perpetual and he didn't
yeah let's back up and show everybody
what we were talking about there it was
all the way back in this moment where
nepo maybe got a little greedy hard to
get there the game is done and Aronian
wins but nepo got a little greedy there
and and there we go let's stay with the
present moment but surely that's gonna
be one he regrets right because he he
had a professional he's shaking his head
a little frustrated taking a sip of
water and we have we have another
English nepo is white it looks like
we're gonna get in English so so far
this is a theoretical battle between
veresov dubious openings by Aronian
and the English by nepo is white so yeah
the same kind of variation as they
played in the previous game so we shall
see who will deviate from what they
played already
yeah well already we ch3 plate I think
that's the first deviation right and the
last game nepo didn't play h3 but rather
was at rook c1 or a4 but you know black
brought the night into d4
here we already have the commitment of
that Bishop coming to h5 which remember
was kind of a critical decision that we
talked about later in that game when
LaVon brought it to e6 so this is uh
this is becoming a little bit this is
definitely different I don't be
surprised everybody if we still see
black play for an idea like Knight to d4
here maybe not right away I think maybe
ninety four runs into g4 defending the
e2 pawn followed by a bishop gobbles
pawn on b7 so but but the knight on d4
idea is just such a common theme for
black in these English opening so as
soon as black has a chance to do what
normally they do and the Vaughan is the
one has officially given us a very good
view of his forehead officially off off
screen now but job but okay he's he is
fully focused and that's that's that's
what's very clear so who won the opening
battle in this game uh I wish I knew for
sure I still feel like black I still
feel like black but LaVon isn't sure
he's thinking I think he's debating
whether he likes this idea of 94 still
and maybe he wants to induced you four
on that line I suggested there's other
moves to consider of course you can
maybe bring the rook over to c5 and
maybe that's overly aggressive I think
in an ideal world black finds a way for
this rook to get involved in something
on the Kings side and justify its its
it's fifth-ranked lift but but LaVon is
calculating how he wants to approach
this position with the knight on D to
Nebo is clearly threatening moves like
Knight to c4 to gain a tempo on the rook
and and then and then continue to bring
pressure to the queenside maybe moves
like Knight d4 and try to use the B file
so so the Vaughn's gone into the think
tank noted nepo is still at five minutes
right that's the starting time control
so uh sony po has played fast enough in
this english that there's plenty of time
and we got some very important
information from Pete this time that the
best move in the previous position was
rook a6
strangely enough yeah quite quite the
computer move but makes sense honestly
from the perspective that after work a6
you avoid that tempo and it's kind of
like the idea was talking about but this
rook maybe puts itself in a position to
eventually swing to the Kings side so
sometimes the computers say weird
counterintuitive things and then you
look at and you go oh that's why they're
better than us because that move
actually makes sense
alright well we get Knight d4 g4 and
Bishop u6 so we've talked about this
position and here comes why using the B
file all kind of moves we've been sort
of predicting here and and you know the
night is on c4
I like me post pressure on the queenside
one is such an pleasant target what do
you do about this point you cannot
advance it and if you play c6 then you
weakened the b6 square is gonna be a
backward b7 that's just no recipe for
getting rid of this pawn yeah and LaVon
agrees so he tries for a counter-attack
with h5 but but now III this night will
have to move and white may consider just
gobbling up that H pawn now that it has
some defense from the Queen on d1 so
interesting stuff there I'm not exactly
sure how how LaVon deals with this I
think he has to bring the knife back I
don't think there's any justification
and just sacrificing the night you take
on h3 but I just I don't think that an
attack like this would be worthy and
LaVon agrees so he he backs up the
knight to c6 and and now NEPA can decide
if he's well I guess the d3 pawn is
hanging right so you can't just take h5
I'm not sure about this III um I don't
like it yeah maybe nepo agrees with you
now he kind of gives himself a little
bit of a head shuffle I thought he had a
plan I was not going to say anything
about it before but now that he started
thinking yeah you should definitely my
theory is always questioning the players
and then look like a fool later so yeah
always question them and those bishop
before maybe that is his plan actually
he defends the defends the d3 pawn by
offering a trade and probably this
exchange does favor white I mean if we
get a full trade on e4 a trade on d1
Anna you definitely gotta like White's
transition into the endgame here because
the D and the B file seem to really keep
black hamper down yeah but it's going to
Peter out I think to many trades you
will take the a5 poem for the b7 pawn or
is there something after Knight takes e5
like I take okay hitter kanji for then
you take on e4 you take the Queen and
then you take on a5 maybe right 66 yeah
I think that probably is the best bunny
paw but I think still in that you're
right in that rook ending I think White
has a tiny edge because the rook would
have been on the seventh ring but
overall yeah I mean close to petering
out maybe that's why Nico took on g6
first tried to gain a bit more of a
positional advantage by creating some
weak pawns and now offers the Queen
trade again probably Queen takes d3 here
instead of Queen takes g4 is is met by
moves like rook to d1 for sure but maybe
he has to go for it and then Queen yeah
and then Queen a fight I agree I
actually think that maybe LaVon can get
away with this I'm expecting Queen at
five now we'll see what he does yeah
indeed he goes for the line that we have
on the analysis board here
so let's see how it continues if they
continue to play like our analysis I'm
gonna guess that white might play Brooke
to b5 here I don't think you really want
to trade on f5 if you're white because
that just fixes black spawns oh and
there he goes he plays rook b5 we are we
are guessing moves almost to accurately
I'll be cheating though what's going on
what it says is that they're not playing
well that's what it says we're guessing
moves that it says we're not playing
well that's the truth I like this room
b5 anyway it's a nice way of attacking
and defending at the same time now I
like that move and okay now the question
is does he want to take b7 and go for
kind of a simplification like you
discussed the a5 pawn is hanging for
black or is there some other way to
build on the tension one move is is okay
he goes for that I was wondering the e4
was an option kind of forcing the
question to the black queen he decides
against it in place rook takes p7 one
one line to be very careful about anna
if Knight takes a5 there may be ideas
like rook b8 check and if King h7 you
have Queen h4 check with a fork on the
rook on e7 uniform so LaVon has to sit
here and think before he moves that
Knight from c6 and he decides yep I got
a trade off that Queen before things get
too real
alright well we got that simplification
and it's it's an endgame kind of like
you predicted a few moves ago I think
white white likes the Brooks on the
seventh rank but White's also down upon
so this isn't the same exactly because
of those double G pawns and he's not
going for the knight trade I think this
is a better chance if white is playing
for the win 94-95 still some tricks I
agree yeah that's a great point in fact
if the attack continues on the on the
Kings side here then this King may you
actually really have a meeting that's
worried about I think f3 is probably
fine now for white yeah yeah he goes for
it play f3 now I again it is a threat
look before and I think you could I
think you could even look c1 yeah I was
gonna say because of rook b8 coming I
actually wondered if he should have just
traded I actually I I was thinking that
I was thinking he could have even traded
and maybe then just played 94 I think he
played rooks
one a little too fast but but suddenly
rook b8 cuz now now with that rook on
the edge rank on I think black is
getting out of the mating net yeah I
think your move was better I also missed
this should be eight that young did not
see and now black should be okay but
this is still looking more like a draw
yeah I agree I mean the white knight is
so strong there on e4 right just such a
such a powerful piece black structure is
is less than ideal as they say right
lots of double the isolated pawns
they're so not good for black yeah I
would be surprised if Nico is and
actually the one playing for a win here
somehow I think white is playing on
because even though you have a see pass
bonus black you can't advance it you
can't really activate your pieces so you
don't have an outpost for the black
knight and the roof doesn't have an open
side either right I agree and also the
the time advantage suggests to us that
there's no reason for nepo Nanaki
playing here right I mean look at that
LaVon down on time consistently in this
match but this is about as big of an
advantage as we've seen I mean this is a
full three minute plus advantage for an
upon me ah she yeah I don't think that
white can actually win this game unless
black blunders but he should definitely
try to play on since he's got so much
time on the clock and the position is
very pleasant for white yeah agreed
and the question is I wondered if if if
there was some way for a white to get
the King involved and I don't know
exactly how that looks but perhaps
bringing the King
bringing the King around to g5 at some
point is an idea for white here he tries
to improve the rook first okay
LaVon puts a stop on any chance that my
idea comes to life here unfortunately
and it's not easy to bring it anywhere
else like to I don't know what to go
towards the d5 square you can turn it
cross it was I think he's going to try
but yeah I think he's gonna try he's
gonna try to bring the king somewhere
and continue to put a poke and prod and
say well yeah maybe it's a draw but I'm
up a lot on time and we'll see how you
handle the increment here comes up looks
like a great move because it's going to
leave the straight
I think Nebo if you want to win you got
to play for f4 here I think
you create leaves this eforp own alive
so black totally no I agree right so
they agreed in that role interesting new
poses all right I've I pushed my hand
far enough and I'm gonna I'm gonna let
you off of the hook with the draw here
despite only having seven seconds so
that means Aronian maintains is one game
lead in the match right and once again
Bishop f4 and the h4 going I'm gonna
write this down and we need to ask in
the post match interview about his
opening choice yeah for sure we should
ask him about this this line is I mean
has he ever looked at this before or is
this just total shenanigans bye-bye
LaVon it's uh it's great to see them
repeating opening because what we need
to experience now is that well in the
previous game black got a very nice
position in the very same line so it has
to improve it and he didn't have time to
check it he didn't have time to analyze
it he has to come up with something on
the board right now yep agreed and this
is gonna be another tricky Barrow
software maybe White has the King in the
center and maybe black can strike with
e5 and d4 we saw this position a few
moves ago and speaking of repeating
things in case you weren't here a few
months ago let me do my thing and remind
you of what you're watching this is the
2017 speech Chess Championship brought
to you by masterclass by the way our
sponsor masterclass has a course coming
out with Garry Kasparov very soon all
kinds of stuff supposed to be revealed
for all different levels of chess
understanding and coding opening
novelties and different types of takes
by the world champion on on the common
tactical patterns and all kinds of
interesting stuff I'm really curious to
see how it happens we haven't gotten our
sneak peak yet Anna we're supposed to
get a sneak peek and actually get the
whole course here at chess calm so we
can give more personal reviews but but
that's coming and maybe we'll try to get
you one to get you to give it a review
and oh yeah and my official apologies to
mr. Kasparov I was not going to talk
over his announcement I didn't know that
it was on the time I spoke at the
beginning
this job yeah I don't worry about in
fact I think we should do that I think
we should run the commercial and do
running commentary and make I like that
idea but anyway but remind everybody
here we got it we've got the speeches
championship sponsored by master class
you are watching the pom Miyagi versus
Levon Aronian and the winner of this 710
matchup will take on the number two seed
Sergey Karjakin reigning world blitz
champion so don't forget it and that's
what that's what we are here doing and
here we move on as still a three to two
lead for Levon Aronian and some weird
stuff has happened let's head back over
to the analysis and and see what
happened over these last couple moves
because yeah and the world to everybody
in the chat I see that ginger Geum is
here with us and several other title
players and of course the chance count
family hello to everybody let us know in
the chat who you think will win the
match and use the hashtag speed chess on
social media tweet us I have never I
have never had more of an ill-timed
shout-out to sponsors happen so I
apologize for that that was absolutely
insane Levon Aronian wins a miniature oh
and in fact so insane that I'm gonna
back up real quick and take a quick look
I don't normally do that but I know that
the fans want to see what happened so
where did this particular veresov go
wrong you can actually you can actually
let's see so let's let's take a quick
look at what happened in this game
because after he took on c5 and takes on
b6 it looks like Nepal me ah she just
blundered this idea of Knight takes d5
and the point everybody was that if he
had taken Bishop to c4 was just winning
the Queen on the spot so that's what
happened right there was he he just
blundered a simple Knight takes d5 and
once that pawn fell the diagonal became
open and as you see the final position
was just an absolute smashing so we head
back over to the live game and we don't
want to lose too much of that because
now we see meepo is he untilled he
switches from the English to the Scotch
for the first time Anna now nipa plays
the Scotch I know that because I played
the Scotch regularly so and he's one of
those top grandmasters that I'm always
aware of what he's doing
so just so everyone knows no pom meow
she plays the Scotch regularly and this
is this is a really dangerous line for
black so maybe he'll be able to
back but I'm interested to see what
happens now that he's gone away from his
English for the first time yeah I was
expecting him to switch between c4 an e4
in this match as he plays both and as
for Levin I think we will see the
English mainly but he also plays d4
openings yeah well obviously we've seen
only only d4 so far right this veresov
here from from Levon Aronian yeah I mean
normal d4 opening sorry for not calling
default before yeah you're right
yeah here comes the community for
pushing to seep on yep alright there's a
threat of Queen takes c6 check everybody
that's what's on your board so don't
miss that and if black plays a normal
move to defend it one of the ideas
behind the Queen on e4 is you also
finally create a situation where you can
complete your development sometimes this
bishop will come to d3 certainly if
black tried to Castle kingside and
otherwise the Queen is just very
dominant there so Aronian having to
think about how he wants to defend that
pawn and he decides it's not worth
defending I'd rather attack and here
comes Queen to g6 we're gonna have a fun
sharp game in this one maybe not so sure
but yeah the Queen's are still on the
board Queen takes c6 Bishop d7 just
happened and who's King will be in
danger yeah good question
White has one two pawns on the Queen
side and maybe the d6 pawn comes under
fire if black goes and takes here with
check as fun as this seems I think the
pawn miasha's idea is that with that
Bishop gone at some point White's gonna
be able to break through on the D file
but the but the h3 brooke is also
hanging on with the bishop here so I
have no idea what's gonna happen here
look LaVon goes for that line where he
captures and then takes the rook and the
question will we see a queen trade offer
or will we see him gobble the pawn with
check either way no Pompeo she doesn't
seem thrilled after blundering last game
missing Knight takes d5 yeah here he's
shaking his head and and certainly feels
like he did not get the best scotch game
he's ever had
Levon is uh feeling pretty chipper
talking to himself there I'm wondering
he's singing or he is calculating but
you don't really see elite players
calculating with their lips moving he's
also got a dog in the room with him so I
wouldn't be surprised if Levon Aronian
was a dog whisperer I'm just gonna throw
it out there that if Levon Aronian had a
second skill one of them would probably
be talking to animals so just a theory
all right look at that he played c5 that
was such a sweet move everybody the
reason it forced castles is because it
unleashes this threat of Bishop to b5
check and the mating a net the mating
attack is on and so he castles and gives
back to piece on b6 but well this is a
weird one this is weird I'm not sure
which color I like here I usually like
to have material on but I don't feel so
secure about the c1 king with this C and
B Phi is opening up
although the D sticks button is gonna
fall it anyway it's just what is this
position Dani I have no idea I'm looking
at and I wonder if the key point is that
the rook is gonna come to c8 here and
and maybe he's calculating some idea
where he brings the rook to c8 and this
bishop will come back to f5 with check
and so that's why that's why I need mo
plays rook d2 because if he had okay
we're gonna get room c8 the line I was
talking about but if the King had gone
to b1 Nico would save our sorry LaVon
would save the bishop would check and
then do this Sony Poe didn't allow that
with rook t2 but LaVon gets rook c8
anyway and one of the issues here is
that there's a threat of rook takes F to
Anna so if if something like Queen takes
a7 is played Black has rook takes f2
yeah Knight this pin there's no 94
anymore so this looks like game over
yeah Nebo is thinking he doesn't want
that to be the case that it's game over
but but he doesn't seem to be his most
chipper self okay he does take on d6 and
I expect we'll see where it takes F to
here because it looks although b7 might
come now right we nixed e6 interesting
if
I mean this is this crazy or what if
rook takes up to be seven sacrifice the
bishop would check and suddenly you may
be able to get a clean over here
rugby eight more accurate it seems that
is game over yeah okay so there we go
yeah and nepo agrees he leans back and
little frustrated with himself and
suddenly we have a three game lead for
the Armenian assuming that this one goes
that direction and potentially a big a
big turnaround will need to be in store
for an e PO to get back in this match
but you know if I had to predict hit
coming in I would say LaVon is you know
is the stronger player I think in terms
of like you know being at the you know
the top of the world's elite I think a
lot of people would consider Levon
Aronian
you know a better than the pom Miyoshi
obviously so I think LaVon should have
an edge and the real question will
always be bullet right will it be a
great equalizer and and help the
underdog and upon Miyoshi or will you
know will it will it will live on it was
surprised us and and and be better in
the bullet as he has been in the Blitz
so far true and look at that hit force
still trying to complicate matters
gave a check on c4 and that bushes b7
but this shouldn't work shoot it now
rook takes d6 is game over reminding him
that the bishop on h3 is guarding the
the rook on c8 so yeah rook takes d6 and
Nebo resigns no he doesn't he knew Poe
is uh
I like his attitude though I mean
shaking his head but he seems to have
like this attitude that he wants to keep
playing in maybe it's because you reckon
d6 and he will have a kinda peace unless
it doesn't look like his position is all
right so yeah this shouldn't be good
just looking at any immediate threat if
you can win more yeah I was wondering if
he would you sack the exchange yeah okay
yes simple enough definitely it's
definitely something worth playing on
right now right I mean he's got he's
he's still got God reasons to play on
here as we have 18 minutes left in the
total game clock of the five-minute
portion after that we will have a very
very quick break to three minutes
usually players get some
take a breath of fresh air and then we
roll on to the 3-minute portion so if
you're just joining us
don't go anywhere the most exciting
moments of this match are likely yet to
come so and I don't expect this to
remain a two-game three-game lead I
think we'll see me POP bounce back at
some point but right now he seems to be
kind of down I think the same man since
the X portion is already a shorter time
control that feel favor yarn already the
3-minute blitz games 11 was very slow in
the first game sometimes giving two
minutes advantage to his opponent he
cannot do that in three-minute matches
yep agreed
it'll be it'll be a huge huge point to
see who plays faster as the time
controls get faster g4 very nice
technique right now by Aronian he's got
this rook this is good lessons for
everybody the rook is dominating in the
center and he's opening up new targets
for the bishop by prying open this this
diagonal g2 becomes a problem I mean is
it still gonna take some technique I
mean LaVon has to find a way to to
advance without allowing any kind of
tricky blockades by the knight but I
think it's just a matter of time before
Aronian gets this King active and
eventually goes on to win this one nice
move rook g3 as well suddenly b3 is a
problem checking out on you guys in the
chat let us know who do you think will
win the match and also try to guess the
final score because it's not only about
who's gonna win but what will be the
score there's money on the line so even
the loser takes cash the more points he
scores the more money he gets
yep great pointer right now of course we
have the four de Toledo we have the
bracket prizes that are available a lot
of people filled out their bracket
predicting who will win the speeches
championship four to two right now in
favor of Aronian but the match is young
and we'll see what the final score is
currently the biggest winning margin was
achieved by I think let's see is that
that car honking car honking by 12 so no
I guess Nakamura be Grigoryants by 13 so
there you go that's our biggest score
margin so far this game has just headed
toward a toward a victory for Aronian
cleaning up things nepo did a pretty
good job finding at least some drawing
chances
case in case neat and case LaVon didn't
have the best technique but this is just
over now and NEPA maybe asking one of
our one of our teammates a question here
probably asking how much more time in
the five minute before I get to take a
break because right now I think he's
kind of frustrated yes he's asking if
this was the last five minute game and
there there was about fifteen minutes
total left so he'll learn there's at
least probably at least one more
five-minute game left and maybe match
strategy he wants to play this on he
does decide to resign but I think that
if he's smart and and drains the total
game clock he can get closer and closer
to the three minute portion especially
if he likes the the faster time controls
to favor him so gamesmanship as they say
right overall match strategy trying to
milk the total game clock to get to the
faster time control so seems to be happy
about the next game or two he realized
that he will still have this time
control he said it's good that they have
one more game to go good okay well there
you go
so yeah you know I don't think nepo is
you know he's basically played a couple
of big blunders right I mean we saw in
the last game we saw in the last game
this this terrible Knight takes d5 miss
miscue where he couldn't take as the
Queen would have been pinned and that
led to just an absolutely crushing
attack here white wins the bishop and
then the idea everybody was there was
mate coming on the h-file let me show
you how that would have finished cuz
that would have been pretty pretty fun
rook takes h7 and queen h1 would have
been a nice way to end the game with
checkmate alright but the next game has
started we have a three game lead for
Levon Aronian
we have d4 again and again he's sticking
with the Verrazano all about he is all
about that varus off today oh but with
the e4 so we are actually transposing to
a Pyrrhic yep so we we've seen we've
seen varus offs from Aronian at this
time nepo doesn't even commit the pawn
to d5 instead invites a transposition
into an e4 opening and that's exactly
what we have here well on so so far
we've seen a pretty a pretty decent
mixture of players mixing it up
especially nepo I think now that he's
had sort of put a little bit off balance
right he's willing to mix it up and try
different positions not beating his head
against the the varus often English wall
but what do you think so far in terms of
what we've seen from these players I
think I think Levin is very convincing
in terms of his play but his time
control is not the best therefore in the
3-minute games it will be crucial to see
whether he can speed up and keep the
same level of chess or there will be
problems either with time or the quality
of the game yep so if time ends up being
a factor right now things seem to be
favoring NEPA but let's say let's talk
about this position we have right here
this is a this has become a weird a
weird Pearce it almost looks like some
sort of Sicilian now right the C pawn
being treated for the D pawn and we've
transposed into a pawn structure that's
very much like a Sicilian normally this
might on d5 is looking good but it's a
typical as you mentioned it's a right
typical Sicilian position exactly a
Sicilian position but black coming with
his major pieces to the c5 putting
pressure on the c2 born and the
fianchetto Bishop on g7 is lovely Bishop
d4 is against this Bishop f4 could be
coming up later on anyone to try this
piece
yeah good summary there and that's what
both sides want to do and I think that
nepo decides not to let this Knight sit
on d5 any longer this is almost also
similar to the English they had from the
other color right so we've seen this
this sort of structure of use is
basically a reversed English right yeah
that's what they are doing yes so uh
we'll see we'll see who unwinds here
better at the threat I'm looking at here
has got to be f4 I think that Levon has
got to decide do I want to push this
pawn and risk opening my dark squares
you should always be aware of that don't
push pawns willy-nilly but after Knight
c6 captures on g7 Levon might have
all-out aggressive intentions like f5
and trying to come with an attack but my
guess is is those aren't gonna work due
to due to white zone darks for a problem
so Levon decides to bring more more
pieces into the game first with rook a3
I really like this move okay
I do like it too because you can play on
the queenside and even on the kingside
thanks to this bouquet three moves a
ruby three targeting the b7 point or
what you mentioned f4 f5 and then the
rook swinging to g3 or h3 it's just nice
to play this position because White has
more space pair of bishops is not that
big of a factor here I believe because
you will want to trade this g7 Bishop
anyway more space is a factor and black
on the other hand well he will try to do
is to maneuver with his pieces with the
Knights and now this Queen f8 move well
it usually happens in this position that
you have just the seventh and the eighth
rank for your pieces so this is what you
got to do make these weird-looking moves
yeah with less space squares are at a
premium right so you see these weird
maneuvering moves but black has an idea
here everybody a lot of times black
might try Bishop f6 and then Queen to g7
and you create a battery of the Queen
and Bishop on this diagonal not the most
common kind of battery you see but and
and white is constantly posed with this
f4 question we've been mentioning white
white kind of wants to play a four to
kick the knight out and be aggressive
but as soon as you do that's a pawn they
can't go back and there's always these
potential weak dark squares so that
that's kind of the dynamic going on here
and but now now Nepos seems to be
unwinding and as this d4 square comes
under light I really like this move
knight c6 he's highlighting the d4 is an
outpost square which means it doesn't
have a pawn available to protect it so
Queen the Queen is very useful in f8 so
you will take back on G with the Queen
control the dark squares absolutely so
he's gonna bring that okay I'm surprised
he didn't play 94 immediately but he's
gaining a tempo another way 94 also
would have would have gained a tempo
because of threats on e 2 but III like
the way this game is headed for black
and I expect the d4 square to become a
problem here it comes
even if this night has to relocate to d7
yeah I think this is fine for blacken
and I think that this is like a good
maroc C bind right wasn't a traditional
Moroccan bind in terms of the opening
everybody but what happens here is you
have this this good night versus a
potential bad Bishop and if black can
can keep the structure the same and this
night can to kind of kind of remain the
dominant minor piece on the board then
he's got control
you know white is gonna use the space
that you have behind the pawns to try to
prepare things like b5 and c5 and try to
open things up but this position seems
to have gone gone pretty well for black
I agree with you I like black and now
what white wants to do is to attack this
night for c5 so at least he has the D
Phi square but it's not the same because
you have a knight to jump to the side
but black has two 9 10 we hope that one
is coming to e6 and f4 the c-4 pawn is
also always in the air so you can't
really do much about improving your
pieces easily as white yeah I couldn't
agree more and I think that white has to
shuffle and and hope for an opportunity
sometimes you even try to sack the
exchange if you can ruin it but this has
been kind of a clinic in terms of how to
play black and the MER oxi bind
everybody if you're curious maybe you
play an accelerator dragon you know this
is a game you can go back after this
match and check it out right don't be
don't be surprised when you can learn
things from the best players in the
world even in blitz because this is this
whole maneuvering approach by black to
get this bind on these dark squares has
been really impressive shout-out to
Grand Master Peter Svidler who is here
with us in the chat that's such an honor
for us that Peter Svidler is watching I
wish I could just give up my seat and
make Peter commentate instead of me yeah
we peter peter did a phenomenal job and
he hasn't done a lot of commentary has
to play because he's just way too strong
so you know the team and such but we
love hearing peter commentate absolutely
and now what white you'll notice white
avoided that trade everybody the reason
is you know you don't want to get a
position that's even more simple and and
the more simple the position is the more
you highlight the differences between
the knight and bishop and how dominate
that dominant that is so
Aronian avoided that as long as he could
and and now he actually did manage to
trade off the knight on d4 before his
night with this nice little trick where
the knight came into f5 because this g6
pawn was pinned to the Queen
but I still think that black is in the
driver's seat here even with that trade
and maybe we don't the d4 square if this
night confined itself to another dark
square he's probably doing ok bishop
that's always gonna be first down
black's knight so yes as you mentioned
that even though what has eliminated the
d4 Knight Bishop on f1 is still on the
board now he's trying for a counter
playing the king size o queen h6 your
cage 3 that is a good idea right yes
suddenly seems to be coming to life a
little bit but it doesn't I have a hard
time believing it can lead to too much
concrete I mean I think now nepo is
deciding you can see on his face do I
want Knight g5 and hit the rook or do I
want to trade Queens he's gonna trade
Queens and then I think if you're white
you have to consider the idea and I've
coming to d3 and trying to give up the
exchange for a night and a pawn on d4
mm-hmm okay he doesn't go for it but I
mean the moment we haven't been talking
about is look at that clock again I mean
III said this game it might have been as
big of a time advantage as we've seen
and I was wrong I mean this is almost
four minutes I mean this is crazy for I
guess it's coming down it's a huge time
advantage for uh for Tapani Oishi so we
like his position he's up on the clock
now the question is how can he progress
in this position and playing this fast
in the three-minute portion will give
him a huge advantage Levin will have to
speed up no matter what
yep okay well he plays tickled they're
back and forth a little bit but I don't
we're gonna see uh are we really gonna
see a professional well now Aronian can
take it isn't this three times brief
load repetition isn't it I believe this
is three times that it's repeated or you
have to go back still to e5 yeah I guess
yeah now it has to go back that would be
the third times we see the same position
and I don't expect we'll see that I
think that nobody goes to f6 now he's
allowing the draw that's what you think
I did not expect that coming but maybe
he was already not so happy about his
position yeah and maybe he also still
thinks that he's almost at the end of
the five minute portion just wanted to
kind of stop the bleeding as they say
right these guys are practical I mean he
lost a couple games in a row and and
wasn't playing his best chess he
recovered their outplayed white really
in that merace bind until until maybe
maybe he blundered this night at 5:00
idea that allowed the trade on D for
Anna because suddenly white did find
counter play and apparently according to
Nepal neo she was enough to agree to a
draw our first Spanish yeah our first
Lopez making magnus carlsen and Sergei
karak am proud to play this line I
didn't expect that didn't expect to see
a lot of Spanish I guess although nepo
of course does as you said play e 4 and
C 4 so we'll see maybe this isn't the
last one we will see yeah he does play
everything after you for Spanish scotch
Italian sometimes even second before he
tried against Aronian I'm expecting that
it be a bullet game ok so what goes on
here I feel like the Spanish is right we
get it we get a lot of these positions
if you're Levon Aronian
that in the Italian seems to be what
everybody wants to play these days it
deviated from the main lines but of
course this is not a new position for
any of these players ok you've got a
weird setup with this night on b7 less
than ideal but white also has a pin
night on a2 so both sides putting a
night kind of on the rim of the board
Bishop g5 is a nice move by neat boat
because if he can eliminate this knight
on f6 this Knight from a tube will come
back to c3 and perhaps find perhaps find
a home on d5 at some point also Bishop
g5 of course just unpinned then I donate
to because now the rook is protected and
black will have to do something about
the b7 Knight you cannot leave that be
zombies around forever
yeah I tend to like White's opening here
and I'm not a Spanish expert by any
means again I wish we had Peter let go
here or you know I'm not even sure Peter
is a Spanish expert but he's a much
stronger
our Spanish experts mr. Svidler mr. Lake
our mr. Joe Peter I think both of them
let's keep these two alright so the
night comes the d8 it wants to head into
e6 or c6 any any square that's better
than it was on b7 maybe get some access
to these dark squares here it comes
alright well we're gonna get the trade
and kind of the line we talked about as
far as why white played Bishop c5 white
white seems to be a little better here
and maybe you can play b5 and try to
solidify that Knights home there in the
center yeah he goes for it I like that
move and now you know why square but it
does keep the d5 Knight so you win right
you have something but you win this
beautiful post on d5 definitely worth it
yeah it feels like White House has an
edge here just from the sense that the
d5 squares a little more aggressive and
a little more effective than anything
that black might get with a knight on c5
I think if you're Aronian you have to
find some way to unwind it's similar in
the sense to the last mission where you
say you have you don't have a lot of
space so these pieces are all kind of
fighting for the same squares maybe you
bring this other rook over to be a dad
Yanni's leaving if I had to guess he's
been drinking a lot of water I started
to put two and two together I started to
put two and two together and sure as far
as why he was typing and asking for
asking for a break and a bathroom break
is going on here now live on chess comm
right well he's got a um he's got a
minute and 30 second time advantage and
decided he couldn't just sit there
anymore and perhaps LaVon speaking of
gamesmanship kind of knew he's watching
his opponent drink a bunch of water and
he's like well let's let's let this drag
out a little bit but okay officially
this is going to be the last game of
this of this time control in case
anybody is wondering there is only 35
seconds left here in the in the five
minute portion Anna so we are gonna take
a quick break and well not not yet after
this game it would break at some point
and and then we will be moving on to the
three-minute portion so I think this is
a big game that
than people think I think I mean a
three-game lead is significant we've
talked about Aronian not managing his
time as well as nepo Anna but three
games is a lot a lot to make up at any
one given time control so given that
this is now going to be officially
moving into the five minute out of the
five minute portion yeah we are
officially we should be done with you
vibe to emotion after this game so here
we go he has made it to the bathroom and
made a good move on the board at the
same time well I'm sure he was thinking
about it these guys don't need the board
in front of them didn't know what's
going on so you don't see people going
to the bathroom in blitz games to green
blitz games but since this is a
three-hour match he thought this was a
good moment well we call that the MDL
gambit right
Maxine Maxime eats and drinks so much
food and water during these things that
I think we've seen him get up on his
time despite the time which will
multiple times so but I still like the
way Nemo's playing and again it's
interesting to know obviously as we I've
already acknowledged neither one of us
really felt like a Spanish expert but
watching white play this position just
from evaluating it from whatever chest
knowledge I have left it just feels like
white is is squeezing the light squares
in a way that's much more effective than
a plan the black has f5 makes sense you
got to try to find a way to undermine
white Center but I feel like the
dynamics here are favoring favoring
white I still like the idea of bringing
this knight to c6 maybe my other Knight
can come from to come to d2 and also
eventually find a home on one of these
light squares look at it look at that we
were expecting nine c6 but he wants to
create a postponed after Knight takes
yeah Wow he he takes and also creates a
dynamic of a but again a potential good
night versus bad bishop we had that last
game from the opposite colors but if
this Knight can relocate itself to any
one of these light squares here you're
gonna see a very very strong minor piece
versus kind of a blocked in black
counterpart there so it's again it still
feels like white is really in the
driver's seat and notice the bathroom
break didn't really
Nepos time advantage he's still up two
minutes on the clock so I think meeples
gonna strike back here we're gonna see a
two-game lead for Aronian heading into
the three minute portion predict I agree
with you I think that's what's gonna
happen because this three-plus advantage
we saw 11 playing better but the apana
she missed chances many chances I guess
I keep I keep forgetting and my teammate
has reminded me so yeah this is the last
five-minute game classical chess but we
have one game 960 remember that's one of
the fun parts of the speech Chess
Championship is a chess960 game which is
Fisher random if you don't know what
that is the pieces are shuffled randomly
on the back rank and you're about to
find out in about 30 seconds or a couple
minutes here so we have one chess960
game which does count toward the total
score so my apologies for getting a
format that I've hosted dozens of times
so it tells me where my head's at but
yeah there you go just 960 coming up I
already see some fun tweets about this
match keep those tweets coming hashtag
speeches and tone squared me has already
cropped a nice video of young and lovin
their facial expressions of birth yes
you need to see it on Twitter hashtag
speeches go and check it out it's all
squared me is one of the best followers
out there that guy's that guy he wonder
what he does with his time if he sits
there and just looks for opportunities
for chess gifs I mean we may need to
have some conversations about his life
choices but as far as the gifts he
creates I love it so his photo shows
ended he gives he makes so you must
follow an x squared me on Twitter and
check out what he has just published
with the hashtag speed chess and also
you should tweet us Danny are we giving
out any premium I mean any diamond
members should of course I don't even
know what we're giving out but we're
giving out so look at this queenie -
nice move because if the brook moved we
a'queen see forecheck
forking the King and Bishop so Aronian
still in trouble here and still down on
the clock Nebo does eventually relocate
this night to try to come into one of
these light squares here and with this
pawn on a6 sort of looming there I just
feel you know you don't want to leave a
pawn that's passed on the six rank for
that long at some
point bad tactics happen right that's
how that's how promotion tactics
happened when you would need to collect
an advance pass pawn yeah but as far as
prices go Anna for sure I mean let's see
let's give away some diamond memberships
for whatever your favorite sweets are
we're just gonna leave it all on Anna to
just choose her favorite tweets oh dude
that way they everyone can be nice to
you on Twitter and we'll see who gets a
we'll see you know but send us the
normal tweets right show us how your
watching the match tell us your favorite
game whatever if you if you have it to
make a gif Anton squared me style
go for it night to be three I love that
move night be three is attacking the pin
Bishop and if you capture with the rook
Queen to c4 check and after the move
Queen to f7 it's just a big fancy trade
I'm just gonna well he's gonna go get
the Bishop on c5 it's just a big fancy
trade but he's left with this pawn oh
six yeah he still had Queen f7 yeah
that's what I met it's just just a trade
but it did help white to bring the
pieces closer and I don't even see any
threats here for black so why not play
a7
okay nepo decides to be safer than that
but I'm my pawn is itching to get to a7
don't hold me back anymore yeah there we
go
yay and because of this a7 move let's
and now that we are expecting pictures
of you why are you watching us from I
love to see those pictures so hashtag
speech as tweeted your screen of your TV
or Val you are where you're watching us
from because I really want to see it and
you might win a diamond membership
because of those pictures look at that
so the the five-two portion is over
which means we have chess960
nepal Miasha wins which brings it to
only a two-game lead for currently from
Levon Aronian but Levon gets white in
this chess960 game look at the pieces
the first thing you usually try to do is
you saw Levon took about 15 seconds
there you sit there and you try to
assess what's going on with with the
position since your pieces are not
developed in the normal fashion you've
got to develop a plan and here we see
him what does he do he creates the solid
structure
opens up the bishop toward the King on
g8 makes sense and NEPA kinda just
copies him right along the same idea
opening up his bishop toward the White
King I love to see chess960 but I always
want to have more time on the clock when
I play it because it just takes some
time to get used to where your pieces
are and what your strategy should be
agreed that's one of the things that
makes this so fun is we basically are
you know we're playing playing a blitz
game in a position that nobody's ever
seen before and and makes it really
weird so this is getting closer and
closer to looking like a normal game as
compared to anything we see though and I
mean White is about one move away from
castling and black already does so the
way you castle in chess960 is you just
put the King on top of the rook and and
the rest is magic it's a weird magical
thing that happens the rook and King
just switch places yeah this is the
weirdest thing I think in chess960 apart
from the funny looking pieces I see some
of you in the chat saying that the bird
is broken somebody can fix it please
this is chess 960 well look at LaVon
Anna like he's avoiding castling and I
wonder if it's because again he wants to
get the H pawn involved we've seen him
obsessed with his H pawn and in in many
cases and we've already referenced his
big win over Anna pom neo she has white
with an H pawn age pawn rush making
Simon Williams proud getting Harry
involved but I think that that's why
he's delayed it and if I if I had to
guess if LaVon can move this knife from
me to and maybe get the Queen out
he might even castlelong this King could
slide all the way over here and then
you're in a position where white really
might still have attacking chances so
anytime that's being taken it was
possible is it isn't really how it is
yeah yeah oh yeah as long as you haven't
moved the king or the rook the king has
the ability to castle on either side of
the board and and I'm confident that
this is what LaVon is thinking about is
how he can how if he can maybe he will
Castle short but as far as why he's
thinking right here it would make sense
to me that he's debating whether or not
to go for some sort of castles long idea
so this should be interesting and this
game counts that's what that's the
biggest biggest point right after this
we will officially have that break I've
been talking about prematurely for the
last 15 20 minutes and then then we'll
be moving in a 3 minute but what happens
on night 2 G 3 let's move over to the
analysis and see I think that I'm just
curious can we get can we get 60 chests
on an analysis board okay he goes for it
I like no g3 he took a while to do it
but I guess now they talk but I like
this idea and I think that after what's
happening in the game if you can just
get the Queen off the back rank here
if the Vaughan plays something like okay
here we go he did what I was predicting
I'm expecting I'm expecting LaVon to
have found his way to do this and if he
castles long and all the sudden moves
like Knight g5 and Bishop h7 are coming
this could be this could be a very very
quickly and sort of surprisingly
developed attack and meepo could be
trouble okay he wants to trade Queens
make sense now that's a smart choice
since danger was coming and you can't
really prevent it because if you go back
well you can still buy Queen f3 and such
but that's not the same your attack is
nowhere yeah I almost think queen h5 was
played a little too fast
in hindsight the first thing I was
thinking was Queen f3 first which what
maybe okay maybe he didn't like Knight H
for some ideas but but okay now he does
have to trade Queen so that is is gonna
ruin the idea that meaning that I think
LaVon is not super thrilled with how he
approach that attack but I wish I could
see this castle Queen side because I've
never really witnessed such a longer
castle I hope we see it too and as we
were just reminded it is the longest
legal Castle possible in chess960 yet
the King on g1 heading over to that part
of the moor okay you could also do it
with a king on b1 heading over to h1 but
and he does it we did it we have history
in the making the longest castle
possible in a chess960 game and he's
popping the jersey right there LaVon was
popping the jersey the Celtics Jersey
and he is still speaking so I like this
move and if Knight takes Jeju Anna the
the rook comes to g1 and when that
Knight moves we've got all kinds of
tactics like Knight f6 check the pawn on
g7 is pinned yeah not only this position
it's gonna get dangerous I think black
of course shouldn't take the position
now is looking very traditional normal
chess yeah this could this could
certainly have been a traditional game
maybe some sort of like classical
Carroll Khan or something with yeah I
don't know it's some kind of attack yes
b1g and actually no longer somewhat easy
Bobby what did she what is actually
longer because the brook only goes to f1
instead of D well I don't know but
anyway but yeah as far as the King goes
oh yeah that's right G 1 2 c1 is is not
as long as B 1 2 G 1 so so that is that
is correct we were wrong that it's not
exactly the longest castle ever but okay
details me tails as I say here comes h4
here comes No h4 I want Harry to play I
know Simon's watching Harry Harry Harry
the H pawn is is gonna get back in I
just seen that mr. morrow sandwich was
also with us everybody wants to see this
match yeah this is a big match I mean on
paper as everyone said this is this a
lot of people expected this to be about
as close up imagines we could have in
the first round now of course that ended
up kind of not being the case if you
missed the onigiri vs. Wesley so match
then you missed a real tweet as you can
see over here on the left side of the
bracket that match went to overtime
it was insane it was a tied match
onigiri was in control up a game with
just a couple minutes left and Wesley so
won two in a row to take that match home
so if you if you missed the Geary so
that was the best right the best we've
seen so far that was just so much fun
but who knows maybe we'll be in store
for another thriller here today alright
g3 of course this position is not as
exciting as the previous games I feel
like this chess960 which usually brings
out the most creative position
in case of these two it brought us the
most boring one I mean I'm not
complaining because this match is
thrilling but no you're right though
this is this is nothing usually you get
like weird positions in chess960 where
there's a queen on aah struggling for
you know to get it fresh air right I
mean here this is this is a normal chess
position this is a hundred percent
boring endgame call it a Carol con call
it a Petra I don't know what it is but
it's not it's not that exciting and I
feel like they would never reach this
position from normal chess I mean normal
openings because it's first of all they
don't play the character nor Panos words
but actually from from the Queen's
Gambit you can get this position if
LaVon would not play Bishop f4 and
second move but yeah they normally play
much more creative pushing the H pawn
early well LaVon again down on time
though nepo plays Knight f6 quickly and
Nebo trying to press his time advantage
a win here would bring him to within a
game and as you've have you been saying
if if these time management struggles
continue for Aronian then a full game
lead is not going to be enough in this
match as the time controls get faster so
LaVon definitely gonna have to pick it
up in the three-minute in one minute
we've already established that but what
matters in this game is that Aronian is
once again down two minutes on the clock
White's better though I mean white white
has an edge here right i mean the knight
on c5 is strong the rooks are super well
placed in the center on d1 and e1 but
but how much of an edge is it I mean
small small at best yeah it's usually
compensates for the isolated poem which
is in this case a structural weakness
but as you mentioned White's pieces are
very active I would expect this to be a
draw agreed yeah 95 are we gonna see a
trade no not not the light square bishop
trade the rooks come to the e-file nepo
continuing to play fast and now Aronian
almost almost down to 10 seconds he's in
the teens
okay so I think meatball might consider
and move like v6 here try to kick the
night no he plays Bishop g4 this is
Jewish position but certainly with two
minutes on the clock
you will not go for any draw yeah okay
Wow why does all three have to be played
there what did we miss
what was that yeah oh okay yeah if
rookie three then Bishop takes c5 and
then is winning yeah so yeah we
completely miss that the position was
not as boring as it looked
well after that move rookie the rookie
to King D to move LaVon sort of self
trapped as work on e2 which made this
taxing happen right so Thunder and
suddenly it looks like what we said may
indeed happen I mean nepo is on his way
to win this game up a pawn with the
bishop pair and up two minutes on the
clock we shouldn't be surprised if black
doesn't come away with a victory here
you know I guess he is just waiting in
the options which pieces shall he trade
how to be more precise but this isn't
good enough trading one rook and then
chasing the bishop away
now it's veered on a three and we see
LaVon shake his head they're a little
frustrated I think at some point oh oh
and Nipah did blunders with rook to e8
and just self pins the bishop everybody
rook to e8 creates the pin and is he
just losing now cuz he has been he had
Bishop e8 he was lucky at Bishop d8
otherwise ninety-seven check was coming
and he was losing on the spot okay but
it's he has no more than a draw and if
anything white might be in the driver's
seat so just not his best portion of
chess ever I'm sure that Yan will will
express his frustration as he shakes his
head and just completely blew a winning
position I was I was we were predicting
the one-game lead here this blunder here
is so far one of the biggest turning
points in the match as you can see
everybody on the analysis board rook to
e8 just a massive blunder the bishop
could not capture because the rook any
other rook move is fine g5 f5
that sort of expand on the three-on-two
majority would have been good for nepo
but he blunders away this game and he
could go on to lose this that's it
that's a two-point swing right Livan
goes back to a three game lead instead
of it only being a one game lead this is
incredible butter no yes Tony not again
and then Aronian just one look at that
well the guy you are here what is going
on here everybody g5 a nice trick
because the point is there's no on
passant oh my gosh and and Nipah comes
back and wins that game absolutely
insane Livan shaking his head the
players should be informed they have a
three minute break
wowzers Anna we got to back up real
quick and take a quick look at that look
at what happened here this is your least
one trick first game so far it was first
of all very boring too boring for that
playing style and second then they both
pawns first 11 with King D - yeah he
blundered he blunders the pawn and then
I just want to show this trap here
everybody after g5 a creative idea but
okay not trapping the rook by force
LaVon can play other moves like King D 3
to get the rook out but after takes h5
and suddenly the rook is trapped there
is no on passant remember that because
the poem was already on h6 I thought
there was on Poisson at first but after
the rook moves now black won back the
exchange and went on to win the game
just a brilliant sacrifice there - to
simplify into a winning king upon ending
because after this transition everybody
white is just gonna be losing the King
and pawn ending so even something as
simple as this blacks King is closer so
a technical win and that was that was
that happened so fast Anna we could
hardly keep up with it yeah I advanced
way too fast and made too many mistakes
we did not see any serious blunders
about 1 or 2 in the previous games and
now in this one game they made more
blunders than in any other altogether
but in the end it comes back to a result
I guess it's sort of poetic justice or
chess karma whatever you want to call it
because in the end I think the result
was kind of the way this game started
right I mean Ipoh was in the driver's
seat as black played pretty well
then blundered and he got it right back
so we have a one-game leave for Aronian
heading into the three minute portion we
have our first break of the match this
game this match seems to be living up to
the hype I expected this to be one of
the closest and if it stays like this
we're in for some fireworks as this one
gets closer and I think this is
thrilling and I'm seeing the check now
so guys make sure that you let us know
what you think about the results so far
the game so far who is your favorite
player and who do you think she'll
advance and face surgery Kuryakin in the
next round don't you think it's time for
the brackets I think it is time to show
the bracket and remind them exactly what
they're playing for so we have only a
one game lead currently for Levon
Aronian as we head into the three minute
portion and as we've shown the winner of
this will take on surrogate Cory Aachen
but we have our first break and so we
are going to take that break by
reminding you who's helping to make this
whole thing possible again it is master
class with their class coming your way
by the one and only garry kasparov
and who knows what insights the
thirteenth world champion can offer
there but we're told it's just about
everything you could want from him
including some secrets he's never
revealed before but we're going to show
you right now as Anna and I wait for the
players to come back is another short
clip and commercial and encourage you to
head over to masterclass and pre-order
pre-order the class by Gary Kasparov you
can sign up early and here's another
reminder and let's take a look
[Music]
checker chess is a game of unlimited
beauty but it's not just check spin
attacks you have to be creative
let's come with King g5 King c2 king of
six can be speaking g7 C 14 to 16 before
Kings a second guessing boom what was
just me
twin takes the knight f5 and it's a
double attack so let's go back and see
what's the next logical groups cure and
attraction and this mate
what an amazing mate I've been thinking
about few ideas that I never used and
what I want to show that's one of my
favorite openings it's not about winning
or losing but of course at the end of
the day it's about what it offers
I'm Gary Kasparov and this is my master
class
and we're back
we know it's garry kasparov we know it's
his master class and we're pretty
excited about that but again let's let's
get things started here with the three
to portion sixty minutes now remains on
the clock and and game is on here we go
here we go
say that again Anna um I was just saying
that the break was not long enough for
me to chew a candy it's okay Danny
huyn candies is by far the least
offensive things I've ever done on chefs
TV so don't worry about that all right
what do we have here we've got the
three-minute portion is underway we now
have 60 minutes in this final blitz
portion before the bullet to remind
everybody and we've had a topsy-turvy
match in the end it's a one-game lead
feels like that's about right again in
terms of this sort of chess now ISM
karma and I think a one or two game lead
for Levon Aronian is probably about as
probably he's played about one or two
games better than nepo so far I'm sure
he would like that to be a two-game lead
but it is what it is and now he's got to
play faster in the three minutes essence
since Aronian has consistently had less
time than his Russian opponent I agree
with you that I think it's justified
this +1 score they switched openings if
you see that now this is the Spanish by
the so-called co-ceo defense
so this g6 set up against the Spanish
it's not so much seen on top level chess
but now that we are getting to the
shorter time controls we are expecting
more offbeat variations yeah this is
weird this is uh this is a an obscure
variation of Spanish and I I was about
to say got a Florrick a triplet work
yeah I was about to say I like white and
I like the opening of the white squares
and I may still like white the the
opening of the light squares just seems
to me like will end up being
compensation for white in terms of
losing the rook but but I admit that I
looked at it quickly as we came back
from the break and
didn't see 92 coming but but still this
seems to be a super unclear position I'm
not sure if a row naeun I'm not sure if
Nepos act that exchange or if it was a
blunder it looks like a sack because it
looks like he's got a lot of
compensation it does look like in Levin
is smiling yeah he might be talking
maybe he's talking to Ariane or a friend
of his or something he may be maybe
talking about how he needs to get rid of
that chandelier behind him remodel that
house because you know this is no longer
acceptable to have those kinds of
devices hanging from the ceiling but I
don't know what he's talking about but
maybe he just likes to talk to himself
when he actually has the opportunity
because this is not something you see
often we see them in so many super
tournaments they know how to behave at
the super tournament now they can do
whatever they want they are at home I
think I lost Danny so I'll keep talking
I love this no no you do I know whenever
Danny doesn't talk for 30 seconds I know
people immediately assume there's a
technical glitch right if I'm not if I'm
not running my mouth and there must be
something wrong but no I am here okay
Queenie five comes in so after Bishop e6
check how do you continue the attack if
you're one of the ice cores rookie one
feels super natural hmm
of course I'd also like I've also I'd
also like to bring my knight in if I
could just if this was bughouse well
first of all LaVon would love that
because we know Aronian is a huge
bughouse fan but if it was bughouse we'd
be dropping a pony on she's six right
now and it'd be over so this Knight
would love to find a way to relocate
itself somehow over to the Kings side of
the board to help the attack
now I've lost Anna I was thinking see
what happens when you think and you
don't talk you know I'm kidding all
right
III think I'm talk at the same time I I
that's literally what I do that's the
only skill I possess I'm already
thinking about the next thing I'm gonna
do okay
all right so g3 is played I think it was
played Anna with the purpose of
supporting f4 because of this g6 idea
I'm talking about I think he wants to
play 92 and then bring the night around
f4 head to g6 but whoa yeah I don't that
rook is pinning the F to pawn everybody
which means that because then if you
take on c3 Queen d3 to fork yeah I think
94 is is the move 94 stops everything oh
yeah that's five only way to prevent it
but I don't believe in this defense but
with strangers after Queen to d2 here
comes Queen to g6 yeah what's going on
oh I see if Queen to g6 I think he can
take on a 5 and then Brooke and a
skewering the Queen I'm the f2
yeah beautiful that is the threat rook
takes F Phi right now and how do you and
I think what is lost
yeah neatly post certainly having
trouble thinking about it you okay he
heads to e2 which which is good enough
to stop the Queen from attacking
I don't know Queen takes d5 threatens
the bishop and threatens Queen h1 well
not a maid but it's looking very
unpleasant yeah you completely went
wrong a few months ago I agree I think
that I think that maybe even the Bishop
e6 check was a little unnecessary or
even this g3 idea as much as I'd like
the idea of making that square available
to the knight was just too slow I don't
know that White's ever gonna get this
plan but don't but don't give up on it
yet right if this Knight comes into f4
the tables could turn quickly in this
one because blacks light squares are so
incredibly weak
okay so Queen 65 Bishop before Queen c5
I expect us to move Aronian have
repaired cut
oh no he goes for the rook I thought
Queen c5 would be played because the
threatens may don't have to but he wants
he wants to keep taking pawns Mina
I mean a greedy guy here a greedy Ganesh
on purpose so that you cannot take the
rook on a8 because the b1 rip was also
hanging yeah yeah he's got everything
he's got more mature material position
but once again down on the clock so he
checks and finds a combination no we
didn't miss this inner miss oh wow that
happened superfast okay he gets this
Jack he will then give a check with the
Queen but is there mate no checking with
the Queen on d5 at Bishop before you
have Queen d2 check so LaVon is not is
not made it but you can see he's
stressed he's leaning in and he's
pulling on his hair a little bit okay he
ends up settling on this move Queen g8
not their favorite square but she does
serve a purpose which is preventing
matin one everybody what's going on here
Anna I'm losing it
this is certain on the position that xi
was aiming for his still material up
he's got two pawns up with the Queen on
GA this isn't that easy
yeah he can't move the bishop from g7
because then one pawn because h6 Falls
right he can't move the bishop on g7 as
much as he would like to look at that
white is taking all the post he can how
to equal material the Queen can move
finally threatening Queen have to check
yeah here comes the allow the the F file
is coming the F file is coming maybe
even Queen f2 right away just the 13 g6
again ah that's right yeah and LaVon is
LaVon is LaVon is struggling to find
what he can do without the constant
worry of the oh but that's got to help
if that Bishop is off the diagonal at
least there's no more makeup yeah and it
was forged after Queen d7 that was a
nice move returning the h3 pawn and also
Queen d2 if King goes to the second rank
now it's black who has taken the
initiative and with this queen of the
second rank and rook after coming but
it's still not so easy actually because
if you leave they're back
and there's Quincy a dog weenie I check
yeah this is this is a classic opposite
code Bishop struggle right at the point
everybody is it's all about the light
squares white white is basically up a
piece and mating if it's all about the
black squares then then black is happily
defending and maybe even launching his
own attack this is this is ass and Here
Come more dark square problems for
whites oh yeah those pawns gone on the
queenside now it's clearly black who is
in charge oh he's he's willing to saxony
say wow look at that
because bishop comes to d5 what did he
we were just lucky six had the specific
intention of threatening this and LaVon
has to go for this now and he's down on
time he he's got to play more quickly
and he lost on time whoa and a strange
but look f7 inverse case it's a queen in
game with a pawn up but not a loss yeah
well he seems frustrated with his time
management there LaVon a little
frustrated with what happened he doesn't
really understand what happened I think
he didn't see his clock running no yeah
well that's frustrating the now he's now
he's taking too much time there I think
we bought a little frustrated maybe
worried that he had some sort of glitch
or something or maybe he had slow
internet for the moment I'm not sure
what happened there but he's saying that
he's disconnected for a second so he
lost some time well we have to have is
he no longer online right now no the
game has started
I'm not sure he knows the game has
started
yeah I don't think he knows that there's
a new game and he's already one minute
below on the clock hmm
yeah well we'll uh that game was you
game yep
I'm not sure what happened there
technical difficulties for both players
here
LaVon losing on time and with it we had
a tight match but the games must
continue the players need to continue to
play as they're losing their chance all
right
as the next game started yet not yet I
think there's just a small issue with
the disconnection is the Vaughn still
disconnected trying to ask my my
teammates right now
we are waiting for lovin to come back
online make sure that you tweet us using
the hashtag speed chests and ask the
pictures that we asked for you know that
I love those pictures photos of your
screen your laptop your computer your
phone your TV very watching us from and
let us know so the city the country I
love to see that the whole whole world
is tuning in for this epic battle
between diplomacy and Aronian tweet us
using the hashtag speech s11 back good
time for social I'm not sure he seems to
be disconnected but we're not exactly
sure what's going on here so we are
trying to make sure we get this figured
out let's give it give it one moment
here everybody and let me let me figure
out what's going on with the team and
and we'll be we'll be right back
it looks like we we have liftoff once
again players are back so far
maybe maybe possibly
we are oh they also gave me one perfect
they also gave me 1/4 of it it looks
like we and yes we did have to give the
Vaughan a forfeit for the for the time
for the time spent and we are underway
that's what matters is the matches back
on the road but but ok still waiting for
for things to get to get a lined here
properly just yours truly flying solo
currently without Anna and right now the
score has now turned after that big win
for an upon neo she with the time thing
and LaVon getting disconnected he was
unable to get his internet issues
figured out in time for a full game to
start and so now he has also a forfeit
loss to go with that that is part of the
rules it's unfortunate when we have to
do it to me when we have to do that but
the the rules are if someone is
disconnected for too long then they lose
based on the amount of total game clock
that has gone by we we voted on one
forfeit win given trying to be as
merciful as possible for for lavon's
internet issues
but but anyway unfortunately that is
that is the story and now we are we are
back the show is back on the road here
with LaVon back in the the live server
the game is starting what do we have
here we have another one these weird one
of these weird perks and LaVon is is
white seems to be better in this one
from what I can see and Anna I think we
have you back with us
I believe I backs apologies
I also had some technical issues as well
as Levin Aronian and now the score is
what is discord and what one game for
nipa Weaver's of one forfeit game as I
just explained to the fans even though
it's disappointing did
was punished because he wasn't able to
get back online in time that is the
match rules unfortunately if too much
time goes by because you're unable to
get your own internet issues
right there's not much else we can do
besides besides provide a forfeit law
says the total game clock continued to
tick that entire time and nepo having
won one game too tied the match he was
delivered one forfeit win which is why
you see the match score different than
the the scores next to their avatars
there but a one game lead for Nepal
Miyoshi Aronian seems to be back in fine
form though stretching and shaking off
his his loss and forfeit loss he's not
happy about that but unfortunately as a
rule that we had to maintain and and
here we go I I think me bow is is much
worse in this position though so we'll
see if Levon ends up striking back and
getting a win I agree with you Danny des
this is going to be tough for 11 but he
shall come back with this game it's got
good chances I see Ben is here with us
in the chat hi Ben hi everyone here on
checklist on TV keep the house nice
comments coming and also they're not so
nice ones I usually yeah that's the
internet for you right nice and not so
nice comments I think it's the best way
describe it nice and not so nice
all right well Aronian is up pawn right
oh no no it's equal equal material but I
guess it seemed like he had a majority
based on this bind he has over here on
the Queen side and currently I guess
White House a debate how do I get to be
six pawn it can I eliminate this night
and go gobble the pawn but in the end of
those lines black ends up equalizing
right back
so Aronian trying to build on that bind
rook to d1 defends the d5 pawn and the
d4 bishop and at some point i expect we
will see something's gonna break
something's got to give as they say and
Aronian x' pressure on the Queen side
looks like it's gonna build to some sort
of material advantage but I don't see a
concrete way for white to move forward
yet either I don't see it either and I
hope you guys are not hearing that
there's a storm about to begin right
where I am
apologies if there's any sound effect
for this position
f-five look at that there's there goes
the storm yeah yeah that's a storm I
can't hear the storm yet on your end so
hopefully the fans can't hear it either
but f5 it seems a little desperate
though I think it's the kind of move
black plays because there really wasn't
much else to do in this position right I
mean blacks pieces are really stuck to
the back rank and any sort of waiting
but but ok Aronian on what maybe with
desperate or not it does look like it's
given some it's given some some new life
to the position we are now being hosted
by someone right there on Twitch so
thanks for that Jake five seven eight
nine whoever your channel is alright the
knight comes into f4 it's a super-strong
move the Knights coming into e6 and
White has a huge advantage in this
position in fact now we have another
hosting person someone person host leads
to another lots of people hosting our
stream all of a sudden thanks for that
alright though the White Nights gonna
pop into e6 here and I think that black
is continues to be in big trouble here
Aronian is eager for revenge after being
frustrated with how those last couple
games went that's very reasonable I
think to be upset and now go for a
killing move a killing attack and that's
what he's doing having two rooks for the
Queen and the screen on b7 is very
unfortunate if white could place the
other hook on the a file and suddenly it
would be very much game over and that's
what's happening yeah any you saw
another person now hosting us thanks for
that little sound effects disrupting our
flow didn't expect somebody to come in
but yeah keep the hosting coming uh you
see them upon switching over here to the
a file and the reason why B as we as we
move over to some analysis we can
actually see that one of the main
reasons why that d5 palm was not
capturable everybody is because the King
was trapped over there and in a mating
net that's why you saw this move g5 and
and here comes butt f4 f4 gets out
suddenly we've he's created a situation
where the king can get out which
certainly going to make this much more
harder much much harder to
I check but after King g7
oh now comes the rook this is looking
still lost for black but there's no
immediate win yeah
I'm looking for a meeting down here for
white and I don't see it yeah you wish
behind your phone on H I'm and that it
would be all soft but you cannot get it
there yep
crazy yes she's still hanging on I've
never seen so many people suddenly start
to host us at once so for those of you
who are a little irritated by this sound
jingle we're trying to figure that out
right now get it turned off but pretty
funny thank you for the dozens of people
who are suddenly hosting our channel and
and that's that's great that's great
thanks for doing that although now I'm
really trying to turn it off so that so
we don't continue to be buzzed with that
all right where's the attack coming from
96 checker we can get another draw after
a sharp game and just a repeat of moves
no Aronian is trying for more but he
doesn't have much time on the clock and
we've already seen him lose on time
active King King d3 g3 rook f8 sand nice
movies preparing to maybe sac on f7 and
do a fork with the king and queen
doesn't quite have the the concrete way
to do it right away but very nice he's
gonna win the d6 pawn it looks like and
after that the Queen is almost trapped
so Aronian completely winning in this
position I mean the the only thing that
could go wrong for him and this one so
far it would probably be the clock so if
he if he doesn't get himself in that
position again where the clock becomes a
factor he should be doing fine now will
he get mated on the other side of the
board whoa
did he just blunder any and its Queen h1
mate no not maybe advocation but this is
definitely oh now it is queen g4 next
move unbelievable unbelievable Aronian
last rated with himself that was not a
game that he wanted to lose completely
crushing in that one and unfortunately
lets it slip and so this match has
really turned around right now we have a
and a half five and a half score for
Anupam me ah she which has just been a
huge turn of events given that we were
talking about a three-game lead for
Aronian toward the end of the
five-minute portion he loses a game then
loses the game on time then and with
with the loss on time we assumed was
associated with his sort of bad internet
issues he restarted his PC which was
something we were dealing with him
privately and he was for four did a game
because of the time of way which we hate
to do that but that's part of the game
so and then with that loss he's he's
down to games and this this thing has
completely turned around well I still
can't believe it and I'm sure that lever
I cannot believe it either he was
leading to with two points in the main
part and lost the last game but still he
was even entering the three-minute
portion with a one-point lead and now
he's just two points behind yeah well
he's gonna have to turn things around
right that's what happens in these
matches and there's still plenty of time
left for this thing to come down to the
wire and and we'll see what happens in
this game here we have another Spanish
with an accelerated a4 line this
position seems like when we see in
top-level chess regularly black bringing
the night from d7 heading over here to
b6 and yeah this is their usual
variation much more see on top-level
chess than the previous one that we
witnessed the co-ceo defense I'm just
wondering if Levin Aronian can pull
himself together because I think
psychologically he lost track of this
match he was just so much superior to
yan the first games and the
disconnection he got frustrated he needs
to calm himself down somehow
yeah I agree and it's hard to right I
mean that's one of the advantages we
always talk about in tournament chess is
you just don't know you know what's
gonna happen in a short time span like
this where you're playing dozens of
games in a tournament if you have a game
like this that may be something terrible
happens doesn't go your way you have
plenty of time to take a SUP seat back
and you know fresher refresh yourself
take a walk maybe even you have a rest
day and kind of clear your mind but in a
match like this things don't go your way
but
you know you get forfeited a game
because you're bad Internet and now
you're really psychologically frustrated
with the whole thing which we understand
but we know Aronian is a strong player
and we'll see if he can be get himself
back in the match mentally he has to it
just not over there's so many games left
and he is such a strong player this has
been his year he has been dominating at
most of the super tournaments so I
believe that he can do it he is very
strong mentally as well he just needs to
really forget what happened with the
disconnection and start from zero this
game he's down to pawns and how did he
do track off the game yep well um yeah
and we've we've kind of confirmed that
unfortunately it was sort of lag issues
it seemed from Livan and and meeting
meaning his own connection unfortunately
but as we said he restarted his computer
we hope that he doesn't have further
internet issues that it would affect his
play in this match so let's let's hope
that that's not the case for LaVon and
that we have a game that's the match
that's decided only on the board so and
alright he's he's up the exchange for
two pawns that's what we didn't see his
we're distracted so he's got the rug but
he's but Dwight does have two pawns for
it so solo going on right now so Queen
b5 threatening to d3 Poe and Bishop c4
this course very logical but look at
those funny poems in the center ya know
there there's way too many pawns in the
center to be happy about but the plan
here everybody if you're black is to do
just that is to simplify the structure
and then try to use the rooks right you
got to use the rooks on the open files
and now if y can get this Bishop to d4
holding the biggest weakness on b2
protected you may even see white get an
attack with something like the bishop
and the Queen lining up on the dark
squares so so I think white is actually
better here just and did he just miss
Bishop c5 for King the rooks no that was
rook a to okay I think despite the extra
I think white is actually in control
because of the pawns but if you are
playing with the rooks in these
positions you want to kind of simplify
and open up as many avenues for the
rooks to to outplay the bishop but look
at that the c7 pawn is coming under fire
and if that pawn falls these two pawns
are just gonna run up the board not
gonna be fun yeah this is really
unpleasant and if you have to play Ruby
7 then things are not going well if he
takes on e4 after Bishop takes e7 the D
pawn is very strong but what you can try
to do maybe is to create some kind of a
perpetual net like attacking the f2
phone giving a check taking one f2 and
then attacking Bungie to just try to
make a draw right if you go for
something like this white white can
maybe stop the g2 pawn but I was looking
at a similar line and I agreed this
might be key and question is can black
hold this position with these two pawns
I'm gonna guess that the answer is no
and it's really dangerous for black to
go for that but we will see LaVon is
certainly calculating it and
unfortunately once again he finds
himself weighed down on the clock and
that's been that's been the story of the
match so far I mean obviously with the
internet issues that LaVon had and
having to for for the game because
because his computer had to restart its
you know but but if you take away that I
mean really the story of the match has
been LaVon taking more time than his
opponent consistently under time
pressure despite playing I think I think
a higher quality brand of chess I mean I
think LaVon has played better and I
think nepo has made more blunders but
but that's why it's blitz and he's been
down on time and it hasn't hasn't been
the best for LaVon today I agree with
you that we have seen a very good level
of chess of course excellent level from
an Iranian yep Amir she made much more
mistakes but played very faster and in
three minute games this is this is
already a critical factor and he might
lose it yeah because of that there and
already you see things like Bishop takes
c7 may be coming right and just passed
pawns going nuts
I mean Bishop takes c7 here let's see
what happens if you take and just sack
usually two pawns on the sixth rank can
outplay a rook nepo doesn't go for it
maybe because he probably doesn't have
to he just takes f5 but at
some point I think this pawn is is this
that's a real line to worry about if
you're black now you better run the king
over and and this is looking like again
another victory for an upon me ah she so
the rails or the train is coming off the
track as they say if you live on Aronian
he needs to strike back in the next game
stop the bleeding and get back on the
board look at that he's still trying to
defend now he protected the C second
point and the f5 on his hanging this is
still not game over it seems this is
good that might be but at least you
don't have connected postpones it does
not just hang this C six points how he
did that was weird
yes it was oh he's got some sort of idea
of transitioning over okay so he
transitions to just winning the kingside
pawns meepo does and and he's still much
better now he's gonna have three passers
which is ally that's that's a lot of
passed pawns now he takes with the H
pawn actually maybe even better to kind
of keep the inchworm together where the
pawns can really hold down the fort from
checks and and Aronian says he's had
enough and just resigned so frustrating
for Levon Aronian to have such a quick
turnaround the match is still far from
over
niebo was down three games and came back
LaVon now finds himself in the same
situation I'm just writing down the
score so that we can ask them about
these games after the match but I'm
shocked I really expected Iranian
leading the three-minute portion as well
and I thought that nipa me she would
take the bullet but now it's going to be
a different story
yep well it seems that LaVon is you know
he's on his heels right now I mean this
has been this has been a rough last half
an hour for him starting with the
internet issues continuing with his play
on the board right now he's got to find
a way to stop the bleeding and strike
back nepo kind of feeling a little
relaxed you can see he's got he's got a
bit of a puppy-dog face sometimes thatin
upon the Aussie right just kind of but
but okay so Livan and nepo both both
seem to be pretty relaxed I think LaVon
is just trying to find himself and and
let go of the of the previous the
previous disaster and refocus his
efforts so this has been Josh's sixth
win is that is that six wins in a row
yeah I believe but about five five on
the board right one forfeit yeah yeah
five plus 1/5 plus whites scored in a
row
I mean psychologically things really
started to go badly for LaVon after he
lost that chess960 game right he
blundered away the winning position in a
couple moves and you know the next game
ended up losing on time but but still it
was you know kind of the beginning of
not going well although you know here
this one does seem to be better for him
but we've seen him not be able to
convert a couple times this is a very
dangerous position for black when you
look at that King on g8 here and and the
potential of tactics on the diagonal but
okay no concrete threat for white just
yet and then take on c4 he would have
had two minor pieces that's why Knight
f6 did not work but it's still looking
very pleasant for 11 after rookie one
all sorts of tactics because he he is
threatening to take on e6 and then jump
away with the night winning the Queen so
there was no night take c7 last month
maybe maybe it was possible yes Knight
c7 and then if takes on c4 you take with
Shaq yeah you're right he missed it but
maybe maybe a rookie on this is still
I'm just looking at it I mean it's like
I take c7 is just winning I mean I was
pausing there silent because I couldn't
believe it but yeah like winning once
again made this not good
I guess so I guess we expect this to be
you know with night take c7 coming it
seems to be still a lot of trouble for
black but I mean I was like I was
sitting there and I again we assumed
technical difficulties because something
actually made Danny be quiet but you
know what I I couldn't believe it cuz
Knight takes
seven I'm pretty sure was just winning
for the one so if he doesn't get this
one we know those problems they're
psychologically really really haven't
having troubles rebounding right now
actually knock deaf six is also winning
isn't like every move is winning like of
six or nine C seven I think he's just
debating how he wants to just skin the
proverbial cat here night night takes c7
seems to be the easiest because if you
move you can just take up some with
Chuck and then probably you're winning a
whole rook so unless there's something
I'm missing Knight takes c7 no he goes
for this he goes from winning the Queen
okay so he probably calculating this
deeper than either of us not probably
likely but why should still go on to win
this and and Aronian should still be
striking back but but some strange
tactics there over the last few moves so
the rook has to be protected with uke
eight and then he might want to take on
b7 that's what's happening now Knight
East seven this is lost for black but
it's not completely hopeless yeah it's
not completely hopeless and we've seen
him hold other tricky positions so
Aronian doesn't want to blow this one
for sure we'll see how he how he turns
the tables and strikes back here and
then we saw I mean that position with
the two rooks right he had the two rooks
for the Queen and he was crushing in
that one and got himself mated so you
know again we're harping on the same
point but it's because that's been the
story of the last half an hour of the
match Aronian sort of just beating
himself right mm-hmm
so he should win this game he's up a
queen but if he doesn't win this 100
right big trouble
well let's hope that for Levin's sanity
that he's gonna win this one and then we
will have him back because this would be
very too much if he doesn't win this
game
okay was seemingly still pretty relaxed
nepo relaxed it's easy to be relaxed if
you're neat bow up three games here but
but this game has some technique left to
be had and again i still think i wonder
if not take c7 earlier was was more
clear but okay it's hard to hard to
imagine white not winning this game
there's no real threats here for black I
mean can white kind of just push one of
these passers yeah he can he just has to
be careful with some tricks because of
the night is still on the board but that
cannot be anything serious Queen c5 was
a nice trick by the way because what
he's doing is putting his eyes on the
rook and if the if the others say so if
the black rook had moved to try to
follow through with a plan of rookie 7
to e1
why would have had rook takes d4 and the
knight couldn't take it anymore because
the e7 rook would have been hanging so
queen c5 was a nice little trick but
nepo not giving up on his idea of
coordinating the rooks on the first
ranked rook to e3 is probably good
enough though because if rook takes h2
you can just trade rooks on h3 and and
and then the a pawn is still a lot a lot
to handle
yeah I think we have one of the rooks is
crucial so there's no danger of getting
mated but 93 maybe your idea was better
but now 93 is still there are some
tricks yeah it hasn't been a simple win
I mean okay now g4 also seems to be
winning here but no but then rook f1
would have been a problem this is not
simple like just any polis and he boys
done this already couple of times okay
he's lost a couple times playing out
these positions just being down but he's
he seems to have an attitude of playing
the games out as long as possible and I
think maybe as part of his overall
strategy to get to bullet Anna just that
he just thinks he'll be better in the
bullet because I don't know that
anything else really explains he's
played a lot of these sort of lost
positions out long and this one I think
he has chances but but overall his his
attitude seems to be to be willing to
keep playing even if he's worse yeah and
I think it's paying a finger out for him
because now after this trade my check
well he can still hope for some kind of
a perpetual yes yeah for sure
Quinn coming back so to avoid rook f4
yeah but now that waiking is gonna get
to d3 and it's it's over
it's Red Rover as soon as that King gets
to d3 now this is getting out of the
tricks of Nepal new she yeah I think
even a five was winning there if the
eddy of the Queen for the night cuz I
think a sixth own everybody could stop
it that would have been up a way to
blunder the game alright but now it's
over nepo agrees he throws in the towel
and Aronian has has officially stopped
the runaway train for the time being and
it's nice to see a recovery of a
recovery win regardless of who you're
rooting for and we have a close match
still ladies and gentlemen so it's six
and a half eight and a half if my score
is correct and it should be how much
time is left in total from the three
minute portion right now it looks like
we have a total of fifteen minutes left
so not much time left but probably at
least one more game after this right and
and so now we have a we have one of
these sort of weird Lopez's with the a
six-night ge7 line but yeah fifteen
minutes left before the chess960 game
then we have our break and then we have
one minute yeah it seems that Levon
Aronian prepared this co-ceo defense 97
and jisuk set up especially for this
match against napoleon she he usually
doesn't play this he plays the Spanish
but he doesn't go for it's kind of
openings normally I hear myself twice I
hope you guys don't but actually I will
use if please
okay dish so I was talking about the
open level chess playing with 1976 it's
actually a very interesting opening you
see that it's a completely different
setup from the huge openings
it's too risky of course that's why I
don't usually put it supposed to be the
most how to put it it's kind of dubious
it's this opening but for a blitz game I
think this is certainly something that
even top grandmasters want to try rook
e1 has been the last move of pneumonia
she'll you see that black still hasn't
castled
and he's not worried about the King he
just takes the pawn on d4 the question
is is there anything concrete against
Blacks King or he will just be upon them
Knight takes d4 next move will be a
capture on f3 destroying White's bone
structure I like black here unless
there's something immediate which would
be like Bishop e4 Bishop and Bishop c6
afterwards when the night goes away from
d4 this is this is looking good of
course he has to avoid immediate danger
rook c8 Knight takes and then Bishop
Knight takes offering the Queen so that
what's going on here what is this
I mean Knight takes d4 offering the
Queen on d1 I just I just can't believe
what's happening there so this sacrifice
was in order to place the knight on c6
and create some counter chances against
the e7 Knight targeting the King on
anyone but I just can't believe that
this Queen sacrifice would work yeah I
don't understand where the mates coming
from and the Queen is a lot of material
yeah look at that damming up bishop c6
what is this well yeah and there was
ideas possibly a Bishop to e5 but then
the c6 Bishop would have been hanging
and so now we've got but after the rook
moves they'll be a move light Bishop e5
coming and it looks like black is gonna
be losing back a lot of the material I I
this has been a really really
interesting attack by nepo and honestly
the SAC looks like it might work out
he's gonna get a lot of material back as
soon as the bishop comes to e5 I wonder
how much of this he has calculated in
the moment of sacrificing his queen he's
surely saw something you don't just give
up your queen like that but it didn't
feel like it was such a correct
sacrifice at first yeah and according to
our teammate who keeps an engine running
so that we don't have to he says
according to the engine white is winning
here and well will white win is another
story but it looks like he is gonna
gobble up the rook on h8 and have a ton
of compensation for the Queen okay f6 is
interesting to try to keep that Bishop
trap but it seems super risky at the
same time I mean now the e6 where's
available for the white rook to come in
at some point if I'm white I think a
simple plan also instead of h4 was just
to play a move like Bishop f5 offer the
trade of rooks and then my rook is
coming into the D file creating a mating
net against the black King so it looks
like Nemo's gonna take this one so
striking back immediately I I really
don't see LaVon coming back in this game
already already White has a ton of
material for the Queen and his King is
in is in tons of danger I agree with you
that this is looking down easy win for
Nippon Yoshi can we bring up the
analysis board and show once again the
moments that he sack the Queen yeah
absolutely and so in the position here
after the move Knight takes d4 where he
just says see you later and then Knight
to c6 so he gets one minor piece and
then avoids losing the another one by
bringing the knight to c6 with tempo on
the Queen
and then as the smoke clears it's just
really open roads and open tactics for
white I mean it was uh it was open
season and now it's open season on the
black king so black ends up getting back
the bishop on h8 but oh and in fact nepo
actually really messed that up I thought
he was just infiltrating on the 8th ring
so as we packed up to show the Queen sac
unfortunately missed a critical moment
I think rook d5 was just a bad move
honestly I think he just thought that
Bishop e6 check would have been winning
the rook but rook d5 instead of instead
of just Bishop f5 which was the move I
was saying for a while I think was
winning for white it seems that he he
still has good chances well of course
this isn't at some point both players
were shaking their head so it's a funny
situation man nobody's happy with their
position right
not surprising nobody's happy with this
position LaVon not happy with how he
played the opening nepo feels like he
should have already won this game and
but we're still playing that's what
matters no checks yeah there was no way
to deal with the threat of of D rook d8
and rook h8 so with that Aronian resigns
and and we wait for the next game to
start okay well roni him back with the
white pieces hoping to strike back again
transposing to a period defense yep
actually black didn't play d6
he's inventing a new way of facing efore
well this is an obscure line I mean
white black can play this way I've seen
it before but you know rhodium playing
taking the most aggressive approach
possible driving the H pawn but with the
Queens traded you don't expect black to
get checkmate on the Kings side so the
Queen's are off of the board but White's
position is still Pleasant because he's
got so much space and after age six you
have to go back to age eight video
bishop left one is the biggest problem
of black it's not allowing your pieces
to develop well like Knight of 696 moves
and blocking the bishop on age 8 and
because of that he's going to take on a
three and take on e5 as as we see him
going but yeah if you can take the pawn
it's okay
yeah I wonder if LaVon either
underestimated this idea one way that
you sometimes try to defend the e5 pawn
is with ideas like the knight on c3
coming into d5 to hit a 7 that didn't
happen here I've played variations like
this from the white side of the park
which are also they're always on the
edge of white either kind of crushing
black or what you see here where black
is kind of taking apart the center so
now LaVon has to kind of figure out a
way to justify the loss of his e5 pawn
I'm not sure he has a way he's thinking
how could he do that but ok he took a
not takes back the pawn
yeah maybe this was actually the best
way but the beauty porn will fall also
so this isn't really just the trade of
course
yeah what's interesting is the once the
b2 pond falls blacks rook is gonna get a
ton of counter play so white has to find
some way to that's why he played a4 and
that's why he's gonna move his bishop
now to maybe get a temple on the night
you know he's gonna try to find a way to
to make make a mess of things so the
black can't just gobble up the pawn on
b2 so easily and move forward what shall
he do now after Knight c4 I mean of
course you have to retreat with the
bishop but after the capture can be too
I like black I know it's still possibly
the night on the night and they're gonna
have eight but I'm greedy okay that's
good ninety five is good but I agree I
was gonna say I think that black can
give up the pawn now and then the e-file
may become something that black can use
here pretty shortly so I also like black
I don't think white got what he wanted
to get with that investment in the
opening running the H pawn but the
biggest thing about the position to me
continues to be the time I mean we don't
talk about it so early normally because
we wait till it's obvious but again you
could just see a creeping away right
nepo just seems to be a little faster
and Aronian consistently behind on the
clock in a tough in a tough position so
- so once again it's a point up for
black and the eight point is going
forward yeah now if you're white you
have to decide you want to find a way to
go after the c7 pawn moves like 95 or is
there something with Bishop to d5 you
know you have an outside shot if you're
white here and at a mating net right I
mean the black king is not ideal on h8
with the pawn on h6 and with and with
you know the potential of black could
get if I could get access to the
eighth-ranked so if you're white here
maybe you want to look for moves like f5
you want to try to maybe open up some
some chances for your pieces to to come
to life against the black King on h8 and
and this what he's doing at the brook
comes to d7 I I still I kind of been
thinking that f5 needed to be played
even before there's a threat now rook a1
check and then Knight g4 check so I
gotta watch out for that I think maybe
Brooke f3 is the best move and but done
the c2 phone will be unprotected it's
not so easy to deal with this threat
without dropping more material and the
problem look on the seventh rank and the
potential threats there you just have a
hard time believing that white is really
gonna be worse again besides his time I
mean like rook a3 even Knight takes c2
if you traded and then once he's seven I
mean there's so many threats on the
seventh rank here that could be looming
oh he's picking up the h6 bone that was
restricting his Kings mobility that was
smart not going for the c2 born just
like I'm not very well placed so it had
its drawbacks as well he was that's why
I went for f5 but it's strange right
with a5 cuz yeah rook takes f6 rook
takes east 7 is gonna head to a better
rook and pawn ending for black ok he
doesn't go for it what did he won there
Luke ch-check 98 yeah rook c8 h e8 and
black was uh luck was fine
he's got something better wants to bring
the knight in to g4 and try to continue
the attack has to be careful cuz White's
gonna come to d2 with the king and if
nepo ends up not getting enough of an
attack then you know he may still be
under fire himself I'm surprised by that
I agree I think you should have just
traded on e7 back a few moves ago and
now now there may still be some
attacking chances for white maybe he
wanted to be to a tricky no no he just
missed Burke takes d6 rook Teague oh no
there's no route 66 Doug because tonight
the Knights not coming to e4 check I was
hallucinating Knight to e4 as a fork
who's here it's not for black yeah it
should it should still be just just a
draw and they and they agree so I don't
know we're both a little bit wildered it
seems by some of the moves that were
happening there but there's still time
for one more three-minute game before
they move into the chess 960 which if
you're Levon Aronian is definitely good
because you need time to get back in the
match and here they go and thanks to
Mike we know this that's always we re
up-to-date only four drawers have been
played in 17 and games in this match
that's that's that's a pretty high
percentage of decisive games where did I
wonder where that ranks as far as the
all-time decisive decisive matches and
our speeches championship but there's
been a lot of decisive games another
Lopez now the traditional variation no
cosy oh this time yeah we've seen this
before but again now here comes a five
yeah we already saw this line and I
thought it was I thought it was better
for an upon me oh she when he you know
if we remember that was the game where
we we brought the Bishop to g5 his white
captured on f6 and eventually had some
dominance over the light squares so I
feel like that was a better one for for
black but maybe Aronian thought that
that was fine so I mean sorry better for
white and but Aronian goes for it again
okay now ephors hanging okay but but no
it's not yes it is no it's not yes it is
no it's not okay fast enough all right
that's kind material Danny now it's it's
a point up for black but the knight from
a2 is not coming out yeah that was a
super risky line there it was LaVon he's
up on time which is rare right he's got
he's got time but
but that night on a - this is exactly
what you try to avoid right that is a
that is not an ideal night for sure no
it's not he has to somehow prevent
losing it but how do you do that I mean
okay one would pin the night
Brooke people and perhaps even better
because you don't want to step into
something okay when we should have six
move right yeah maybe he's making it
he's holding onto the pond so far nepo
unable to fully punish that night on the
rim
yeah what about now either Bishop f6 or
efore yeah I'm wondering which first I
think maybe e4 first and after Knight
yeah he goes for it after 94 he has
Bishop to or he can even play Brook
takes e4 but no he goes for Bishop f6 I
think I think Orlov Ana's has proven
that pawn capturable right now yeah even
though it wasn't the first line he
managed to keep his knight alive and if
basics had to be played then I think
like is just fine the night hanging okay
white wins back a pawn but then I shall
not be captured and a c4 phone will
still be handy yeah
likely had it likely headed for a draw
though I think would best play at this
point the the biggest thing I'm
surprised about in this game is the time
management I mean LaVon really picked it
up this game playing faster and we'll
see if that continues to be something he
does as they had to transition into the
bullet but right after this everybody
remember we have chess960 and then okay
chess960 Levon Aronian will get white
again I believe in the chest 960 game
which guarantees him black in the bullet
chess960 game because he will have been
white twice from if I can remember the
games accurately so does black have any
real winning chances here is the
question he's up a pawn right but White
has no other weaknesses to speak of
the night on f5 has established well for
white so I mean outside of time pressure
mistakes I think this probably should
just be a draw and is that in that rain
behind you that we hear is that rain is
it raining where you are no not this
time before there was a storm but this
time I'm okay oh okay I keep thinking I
hear some kind of something happening
yeah we're just hoping for lovin to
score because I think this three point
difference is a bit too harsh for how
well he played so in this game I'm
rooting for him to score and then the
match would be more interesting yeah
agreed
and he's trying to unwind and try to
convert this pawn advantage
all right King to g2 black is black is
why does it be super careful here
because the flat gets the knight to f3
that's a that's a mating yet yeah white
wants no part of that so he takes and
and now is he just gonna win back the
pawn or a black has f6 here we'll see
black might have f6 or okay rook c5
Aronian is gonna do his best to try to
keep winning chances here but it's
getting closer and closer to see me not
possible though here he can move the
bishop yeah and after if Brooke takes d4
there would be f5 everybody forking the
for King to rook and Knight okay well he
managed to get f5 this is strong
actually yeah now the his chances are
improving with the bishop on d4 36 I
like but this reckon game is still
unpleasant with the e3 weak one yeah he
actually has winning chances here e5
that's a bit puzzling I thought he
wanted to go for Roxy to roots III
you
g4 that's a good idea this is how you
should defend trying to liquid it
exchange phones until there's just one
point on the board left yeah and but if
you get the King opponent even you
definitely winning chances almost always
King upon turning offers better winning
chances than a rook and pawn ending he's
trying his best he's trying to work
himself into a chance to win this as
black okay so are there any real winning
chances here he's thinking about it down
on time unfortunately for Aronian right
where he's been most of the match and
struggling I think to come up with ways
to win this one yeah once again it's 717
seconds left and with the two second
increment this is not very promising
yeah yeah well what's he gonna do to get
himself way down on time he needs to
move there you go and okay well still
shouldn't have any business losing but
he has gotten himself down on time so
we'll see how he tries to handle this
maybe now he's just gonna repeat no not
done yet gonna bring the King around try
to go get the cheap on but no yeah too
much but he declined the draw and he
still trying right so if he trades wrong
I was just gonna say Kenny trade rooks
cuz now if now if takes takes king of
for king up and king of five isn't he
just losing he's calculating that's
about the young ones I guess he doesn't
play King of six okay I think it yeah
King of six was a problem and if keep
Dixie for King g5 I hope that that was
actually I think that that was losing
helm what I mean
nepo didn't go for it but he was
cleaning with check that is fascinating
I'm not I mean okay like somebody have
to check that
later but something something told me
that that was not right
but Aronian is trying to win i mean
desperate to get a point back he may end
up losing it right I don't think so I
think he's gonna get a draw but being
down on time it might have been a better
math strategy actually to just call it
and move on to the chess 960 but but
okay we'll see we'll see how this plays
out maybe now they finally take a draw
LaVon recognizing that he's tried a
little too hard yeah I don't be a good
idea of it five seconds on the clock to
actually agree to it yeah and he does
just that so uh there you go
he takes it takes the draw and we have a
chess960 game once again with Levon
Aronian getting white quickly playing
the move g3 which makes sense you almost
always like to just open up these
bishops as soon as you can in these
chess960 games but uh but okay this will
be interesting g6 and f4 that I don't
giving an evaluation of these is about
us is about as hard as playing them I
you quickly have to try to assess some
idea of getting a structure that you're
comfortable with without missing any any
blunders yeah white aggressively plays
d4 and I think if you can he'll he'll
bring the nine out behind the e pawn or
maybe even Castle kingside quickly but
here black should maybe just take and
then play Knight f6 and develop with
some sort of tempo and gain some time to
get the pieces out looks like that's
what nepo is gonna do yeah and where do
you go with the rook if you have to go
back did you gain anything with this
rookie - makes more sense trying to be
smarter so that you actually don't lose
the tempo and culture or maybe you look
like you don't lose a tempo but I agree
with you it doesn't look like that like
white gained a ton with that though okay
so I can put the bishop on b2 maybe a
four first but I can put the bishop on
b2 and then still try to get some sort
of castles long this castling is still
so puzzling to me in chess960 i thought
that you can only
so queenside in this position since the
rock was only eight in the initial
position but no no you can cancel the
either side of the board yeah as long as
the king of rock evan moved and it is
optically weird okay interesting the
bishop comes to be seven he's nepos
trying to be aggressive before white can
get the King out of the center because
if white captures here and he captures
back this Queen is infiltrating very
quickly on the diagonal and and LaVon is
is agreed that this is critical he stops
to think for a moment decides he has to
trade but here comes Queen h1 yeah I
like it
yeah this repeat it wasn't that smart in
the end yeah there's several moves here
for black including 94
oh no not 94 because the queen is open
yeah that's what's one thing that's
weird about chess960 is you miss weird
tactics yeah so 94 not possible but it
does seem to be really really risky
right now I think he'll play Bishop a3
and if you're Aronian you want to play
Bishop a3 Queen to d3 those are your
next two moves and then try to get
castled long so if not for d6 you better
believe he wanted to bring his Queen out
and although there's Knight takes g6 a
move I don't like this d6 at all I was
going to say the e6 hanging knight he's
not looking good
well you can't quite do it yet but
Knight takes g6 H takes g6 and Queen
takes g6 with check certainly
interesting followed by counsels long
that would have been that would have
been really funny
man maybe white would have had an attack
Aronian decides it's unnecessary but
maybe he'll regret it look at that 19 g4
and now now you can't put the Queen on
any of these landmine squares there's
weird tactics coming with Knight F to
check
I actually suddenly like blacks position
I wonder if Ronan should have gone for
that cuz he's gonna lose his right to
castle with Knight F to check and have
to kind of move everything over by hand
try to bring the King to b2 after Knight
have to check
when you have three you have to move the
king then he can cause on a funny way
placing the king gonna be two and then
bringing the rook but it doesn't feel
that safe with the bishop on h8 I
thought that might have been some 94 at
some point if the kinga zombie - yeah
although now he's other than the b3 pawn
being a target on this open B file he's
sort of gotten out of the worst of it
and nepo kind of shaking his head maybe
not thrilled with it what his approach
was that's a good move - I like that
move if you can trade Queens I think the
endgame is probably better for white
mainly because you suddenly notice how
bad this a five point is that's a real
problem
right yeah clearly not satisfied with
this position yeah definitely definitely
frustrated losses the a5 pawn and still
has some chances I mean obviously Black
has been more coordinated than white for
some time now the king and rooks still
completely undeveloped but if you can
play King C to move the knight and then
run the a pawn White has got an easily
winning plan that that's pretty
straightforward if this white knight
comes to c6 and he starts running the a
pawn I think it's just over that a pawn
is just way too strong okay so d5 is a
nice move he's actually trying to stop
knight c6 cuz he threatens he opens up
the idea of the Brooke coming up I
expect him to see two from Aronian yeah
and then he has to solve the problem of
this a five-night probably with 97
heading towards c5 so that you can push
the a pawn
yeah maybe that's what LaVon is thinking
about right now going Knight to d7 first
I think both makes sense both king c2
and night b7 and no he goes nice e6
interesting
hmm okay I a little surprised by whites
approach but he must have been there
must have been more tactics coming with
d4 and captures on c3 and maybe that
we're coming down then we realized
because LaVon felt like he needed to
make some defensive measures there
against the center pawns the biggest
issue again is once again time right 50
seconds currently the time advantage for
an upon Miyoshi and Aronian down on time
is in trouble if it stays that way this
check is unpleasant because you either
open the bishop diagonal and create a
pass bone on yes maybe he has 95 though
he's got 95 or d4 I think both of those
moves are like if black takes with the
pawn here maybe he's got okay he ends up
taking with rook I wonder if there was
some way to go into a rook ending that
nepo didn't like takes with the rook now
now the a pawn is it's got to be on the
agenda as soon as you can you want to
start rushing that pond is he aiming for
some kind of a repetition by giving
check and attacking the deep pawn but I
just don't think it's because I'm so
yeah I think the one I think LaVon would
just give up that a point I think as
soon as these threats are done this a
pawn is gonna start rushing this looks
lost I thought that it would take back
on e3 with the pawn and have some
chances I like this move 95 the only
chance I think now for black is g5 try
to undermine it and not let it just
transition into a rook ending where
that's where this pawn is just running
up the board but we've seen a crazy turn
around in chess960 already right he goes
for g5 that's what I expected okay and
here comes the here comes the foot she's
just gonna make the rook sacrifice
itself shall dr. Jan she's also here
with us in the chat Jan is going to
commentate tomorrow on the Fabiano
Karina holy fun match together with
Dennis so you should definitely tune
into that match it's going to start
somewhat later because your fun is going
to play from Beijing
I believe so you know some what time it
will be in China when they start the
match its it'll be 6:00 a.m. the next
day so we will be starting
the match tomorrow at 3 p.m. Pacific
time that is Fabiana Caruana versus how
you fund and me and Jen Shin hottie will
have the call as you said and
it'll be 6:00 a.m. the following day in
Beijing so should be should be a fun one
there holy fun big underdog against Fogg
on a car wanna but really excited to see
that match ok well it looks like LaVon
is gonna convert on this one barring any
unforeseen craziness but yeah Knight a6
comes in the queen is coming and we have
moved on to bullit ladies and gentlemen
okay well wow I mean that was some crazy
three minutes section of this match Anna
I don't know that we've ever seen crazy
out game done this in chess960
I don't know but I loved it it was so
exciting it was it was so exciting it
was crazy it was it was sort of marred
by some of the earlier issues at the
start of the time control if you missed
it we had some connection problems for
Levon Aronian or he had some connection
problems actually lost on time because
of one game and connection problems and
then had to restart his PC because he
was disconnected from the server and
suddenly we have a forfeit loss so
anyway what matters is the score is is
is a two-game lead for Nepal Miyoshi as
we head into the one-minute portion but
because we have to do that fast but we
owe a quick shout out to our sponsors I
just want to remind everybody what we're
doing here the speeches championship in
it is brought to you by masterclass so
let's take a quick look at at our at our
masterclass commercial that a lot of us
have seen many times now maybe we'll
provide commentary to it this time the
the the commercial that is starring Gary
Kasparov and his master class I'm just
kidding we're not going to provide
running commentary but definitely
consider checking it out
[Music]
check chess is a game of unlimited
beauty but it's not just check spin
attacks you have to be creative let's
convert
kingi five kings c2 king of things can
be streaking g17c 14 to 16 before Kings
a second guessing boom what was the
estimate twin takes the knight f5 and
it's a double attack so let's go back
and see what's the next logical moves
skewer and attraction and this mate I've
been thinking about few ideas that I
never used one I want to show it's one
of my favorite or breaks it's not about
winning or losing but of course at the
end of the day it's about what it offers
I'm Gary Kasparov and this is my master
class and boom white wins yes as they
say that's that says garry kasparov says
I love that line boom white wins at the
end of the day it's not about winning or
losing but at the end of the day it's
about winning or losing if anybody
didn't see that tweet from a nice giri
did you see their loss to Wesley so
unfortunately for the Dutchman one of
the funniest tweets ever about Kasparov
return but the the what we have here is
sorry my teammates making jokes in chat
that I don't want to read what we have
here is a quick look remind you tomorrow
is Fabiana corner vs. hoagie fond you
can see it on the right side of your
screen there the match that will feature
the former women's world champion still
strongest women's player in the world
really bar none unless you - poker comes
out of retirement it's really not close
so
so apparently one reminder is is that
there's never actually been an upset in
terms of seating in the speech Chess
Championship so far last year if you
remember Magnus Carlsen playing a car
Nakamura that the favorite one in every
match and so that's kind of what we're
seeing here no problem Yoshi is the is
the favorite in terms of blitz even
though in many people's eyes Aronian
what's the favor but without really any
other further ado let's jump back over
to to what's happening I am getting set
the round has begun and we have 30
minutes now of bullet chess which should
be a ton of fun and as everything is
updated and set to go checking with my
team we are back and ready to rock the
game has started the clock has started
ticking down we have another one of
these Rui Lopez's that we've seen before
already it's gonna be about bullet if
lavon's gonna come back in this match we
know he's frustrated having lost a
couple games in three minutes that he
wishes he could have back but the bottom
line is this is still completely within
striking distance and even though as my
client told us there's never been an
upset in the the speechless championship
bracket history the favorites have won
every every matchup I think people would
agree that that's that's kind of a stat
that's just Bart you know just waiting
to be broken because of those of you
remember Sasha crook beat Levon Aronian
last year in a match that also basically
went to overtime onigiri lost to Wesley
so yes Wesley soul was favored but that
that match was really uh nice Gary's to
win with 30 seconds left and he found a
way to kind of lose it so I think we're
I think that we're waiting for an upset
an upset is bound to happen any day in
this speeches championship but what
matters right now is it's a two-game
lead for Anupam Miyoshi as you can see
ten and a half eight and a half time for
LaVon to turn on some bullet skills or
nepo to show why he tried to prolong
this match as we saw him do and many
games he prolonged it to try to get to
the bullet Heath I think me both thinks
he's the favorite and bullet and for
good reason he's up on time and this one
and just up a clear pawn I have no idea
what happened in this game because I was
talking about Holi fawns match tomorrow
but this just looks fantastic
stick for white and that night on d5 is
good and the black king is open no real
chances for the G file to become an
issue so but bullet is bullet for a
reason things happen fast blunders are
made things change quickly so we never
want to call a bullet game until we
until it's over but but this one looks
really tough for LaVon I'm surprised
there aren't tactics on the chief
already yeah and NEPA says I'm gonna I'm
gonna force my way through on the G file
brings the rook up he's preparing to put
pieces here and you know and he actually
finds that tactic makes it work and I
think a loved one will just resign and
so with that with that we have a three
game lead for nepo he gets the first
game of bullets so far showing why he
felt he was the favorite bullet Anna and
really actually taking that one home I
just wonder if Levin can stop her turn
tables because he seemed to be so
confident and by prepared in the five
minute portion and since this
disconnection incident happened to him
unfortunately he wasn't the same yeah I
agree
although I do believe that in all
fairness turnip Omni Oishi I don't think
he's winning just because of that I
think nepo has played faster he's been
up on time in the critical moments and I
think I think LaVon has beaten himself
certainly in a couple games you know
whether it's beating himself with by not
having his best connection you know we
got it you got to secure that that's
that's part of the agreement with the
players and by beating himself by losing
a couple winning positions so I agree
with you I think that I think that this
match is closer than three games
I think Aronian is certainly gonna be
frustrated by those losses if it comes
down to losing the match but the truth
is the truth is nepo has played faster
and down on time a lot of Roane ian has
made mistakes under time pressure and
that's what happens in blitz so we'll
see here I'm sorry
sorry I didn't hear you no go ahead I
was just saying that I think you were
right that even though that was a
disconnection nepo Mia she has been very
consistently playing Fox from the very
first games on even with five minutes
games he was like two minutes ahead on
the clock all the time in one or two
games but every game so that's something
that's paying off for him right now yeah
absolutely
well what I'm always waiting for as we
get into the bullet portion here is it's
what's going to happen when we start to
get some blunders and bullet I mean
right it right now the both players are
still playing pretty good chess and I
don't expect them not to do that but you
always wait for blenders to happen and
bullet you see who kind of holds it
together who has the better nerves I
like a row nians position here I love
that pawn on c7 I know and I like the
bishop hair I don't really think that
take c2 is that big of a deal because
black still has light square problems
but we'll see
time is now getting closer to equal
LaVon was up on time on this one but now
we're now we're much closer to equal 25
minutes left total in the match this is
a this is going to come down to the wire
especially if LaVon can get a couple
wins this this this match is not out of
reach at all for LaVon despite being
down eight and a half 11 and a half so
how do you promote this seafoam because
it's looking lovely on c7 but you need
to somehow is Bishop takes g3 though
craziness
are you kind of bobbing his head I think
he's just gonna take a draw my things up
but no his objective for this game
where's the mate coming it's coming on
f1 that's where it's coming
not anymore look at dad nothing anymore
though can he just get a queen cuz if he
might be just reading her yeah he's just
up a ton of pieces now I mean it's two
queens okay well it's a lot of Queens
the biggest is Bishop c3 or Queen c3 any
of those moves were good he blocks it
he's got plenty of time but he doesn't
have enough time on the cloudy mouse
slips
I know whoa wait a second it's not over
yet he still has a mating net did he do
that on purpose then no no he didn't he
mouse lucky here you could see he leaned
back in his chair totally frustrated but
he's still up a million and a half
pieces somehow somehow he's still
winning this game that is insane in st.
E's trades queens in Levon Aronian and
Nipah laughs that he says GG and the
chat he's like okay wow that's crazy
well okay how often do you see somebody
Mouse slit Queen e2 anna queen takes f2
was just it was game over it and then he
oh wow okay well all that matters is we
still have a close match that was that
was an exciting game and now we have
another Lopez Miller and nipple yah
she's not going for the perpetual check
run it was a very good score for him in
terms of the final result but I think he
made the right choice I mean LaVon I
mean at one point he had two seconds on
the clock with with a one-second
increment right I mean he was literally
and given the LaVon has already lost the
game on time I'm impressed that he held
his own there yeah I see by the way a
tweet with the hashtag speech s you
should use the hashtag Erik Nielsen is
saying that let's hope Levin has a
hidden from me at least talent for
bullet and make this much very exciting
I don't remember
what was the score in the bullet portion
between Grichuk and Aronian last year I
know Michel hear me and look that up I
forgot
I know Grichuk I think was up by a game
or so but it was close I don't remember
what the I don't remember what the
bullet score was but I don't think LaVon
was outmatched in a way that we see you
know
Magnus outmatched Grichuk and their
magic bullet right or Hikaru Nakamura
outmatches bullet I remember it was very
close so so so far it's 1 1 in the
bullet and we'll see how that holds up
Lippo now back to being up on time LaVon
nervous he's kind of kind of kind of
nervous rubbing his head I think he's
you know trying to play as fast as he
can it's clearly not he's not that
comfortable in bullet I think that's
easy to say he's yeah not his favorite
time control he might be playing bullet
Ches under a fake username that happens
often with elite players I think that
they don't want to reveal that they
actually practice at least he must have
been practicing for the speeches
championship yep well we know if you
look up on a palm neo she's history he
was practicing for the speeches
championship by losing suit to uh I
think it was a Galka yeah yeah right
before this dream but he he said he was
just trying to you know throw LaVon off
his game and maybe lose a few games on
purpose so all right rook to c7 that's a
strong move and and the 7th rank looks
tricky for white and then what happens I
guess the key is that if that bishop
moves g7 is a problem that's the key if
that bishop moves g7 is a problem so he
has to defend it and but but in doing so
and I don't I don't see a concrete
follow-through after that yeah it looks
like Aronian has kind of wiggled his way
out of that pressure he's got Bishop e8
now and he can try yeah okay even with
the trade at 9:05 check which I okay I
was expecting him to take and play not
if I check
who's better here good question I love
the knight on e4
but the d5 one can fall that's the only
problem I see for white yeah but if the
B to pawn Falls I mean here comes here
comes the the a pawn running and just
letting the chat know we are always
listening to your feedback always trying
to get better at everything and I think
I agree with you less analysis board
let's focus on the the action and the
clock ticking away and what mate okay I
I wonder if he should just sack there he
didn't have gotten himself in trouble no
he didn't
I thought Levon may have gotten himself
in trouble but no he does find a way to
wiggle his way out Levon is gonna strike
back here and with it take the bullet
portion just gobbling up every pawn and
with it he should go on to win this
position pretty easily
again barring some sort of mouse slip or
some other sort of blunder this should
be a pretty easy win for black moving
forward with the two pawns how to do
that now oh but now the problem is he
only has five seconds what's happened
there
yeah what's happened there he actually
is in trouble suddenly what is going on
no he still manages to win actually this
is still well your trade those pawns but
the king is far away the white king is
cut on the white king is way too far so
it is easily winning a nice frontal
attack technique right not it not
exactly the way you expected to see but
if anybody has time to back up and see
this bullet game that transition by
black to be in the correct position with
the rook behind the pawn was pretty
pretty impressive and anyway you would
be well-served to back up and check out
that rook ending cuz that was that was
pretty impressive by Aronian to win that
with literally no time on the clock and
that was awesome so now it's only a one
point difference that's getting exciting
Aronian winning 2-1 so far in the bullet
yeah the tides are turning a little bit
chess is uh well chess is not always a
game of momentum but bull
chess is a game of momentum and the
speech chess championship often comes
down to momentum that's why you see
players win games in a row other players
have trouble letting go emotionally or
psychologically of a previous loss we
saw nepo went five games in a row
already at some point in this match and
but now LaVon has won a couple games in
a row we'll see how that plays out with
only 17 minutes left I knew this was
going to come down the wire we could
never write the story right the drama is
insane because LaVon is not happy with
how he got into this position having a
three-game lead earlier in the match for
those of you just joining us but what
matters is it's gonna be a close finish
it seems like we may be in store for a
photo finish here they're going for that
and we appreciate that the fighting
spirit is bringing in more and more fans
to enjoy the game that they have been
putting on quite a show for three hours
already two and a half out it's gonna be
three hours in total and stay here of
course until the very end because we are
going to interview the players that's
right I was I was wondering if this was
the best idea to push e6 obviously the
Vaughn went for it so Who am I to judge
but it looks like that a six pawn is
gonna fall at some point the question is
what will happen next I think now white
has a choice do I play h4 and try okay
and he does it right as I highlight it
because I think if if black doesn't go
for this then then white White's gonna
get an attack now with h5 okay he's
basically saying if you play wrote a c6
he would have had rook takes c8 that was
the idea mm-hmm and with Bishop takes c6
now the attack continues and we do our
best to try to understand this as they
play faster and know more than we do so
we're lucky if we can highlight a move
right before they play but once that
rook comes to e7 b7 is falling and and
he's gonna goblet yeah I think Aronian
is in the driver's seat here I don't
know if he's gonna be able to get a full
point here but I don't think why should
lose this game in a pawn up via pawns of
course doubled pawns on the B file and
now the b2 pawn is falling but he traded
it for the apron so this is a B passed
pawn against a pair of bishops but those
bishops are not active so this is just a
nice position for white yeah now there's
now there's all kinds of weirdness
coming I wonder if he almost had Knight
'if 5g5 there I think he had 90 xg5 and
Bishop e5 check because on King BJT at
Bishop d6 so we're lucky when weekly see
checked what that will have been very
nice if he had sacrificed and been back
that's neat
and I think that was there but he didn't
he didn't quite see it so white is still
in the driver's seat look at this plan
Ana he's gonna bring the knight to f2
and at some point the Knights gonna come
to g4
ah but but Nico says no thank you hmm
what's happening here the rook is
hanging on on b7 everybody cuz if Bishop
a6 check coming he has to he has to
watch out he sees it but now he's in
trouble
no he bails out with Knight f6 and the
threat of mate on rook h7 wow this is
crazy ship t3 King moves at least you
have the h7 Square covered oh he does
yeah oh he mates himself oh I thought he
wanted to go to h2 what is this
no big loss nepos strikes back wow that
was that was a big win and nook and look
at that he wins a big game and he goes
back to his English will he finish the
match on an English kick but that was
that was the match going from being tied
to NEPA being back up two games and
again that Levon Aronian was in the
driver's seat but that moment that we
were analyzing I want to back up because
I feel confident that uh that I was that
I was right there and there was a
winning tactic for white and it was this
Knight takes g5 would have been winning
on the spot with this move Bishop e5
check I guess obstacle bishops okay hard
to say he's winning but alright we have
an English long story short we have to
focus on what's in front of us because
we only have 14 minutes left before all
is said and done we have a stopping
intimated was just unexpected from Levin
Aronian biggest mistake of the match and
of course this mouse lee but at least he
won the game where he must slipped
queenie - yeah that was hilarious yeah
I've never seen that yeah it's already
on Twitter don't worry it's saved for
the rest of humanity
yep crazy crazy stuff we have the knight
on d4 only 13 minutes left in the clock
both players are just completely zoned
in right now yeah how often is your
position with so many pawns on the
seventh rank like c7 d77 f7 that's
looking various yeah here comes the
knight to c5 or a5 both are possible he
posed in the driver's seat in this game
for sure this is a tough position right
now for black and Aronian passes chess
to struggle to stay in this one after
losing that last game a three-game lead
Anna with what will probably end up
being about 10 minutes left could be
almost decisive for Nepal Miyoshi so you
know it's not a must win situation
mathematically yet but it's getting
close to it the pom neo she is in the
driver's seat and LaVon has to find some
way just to hold this game at least raw
if LaVon at least draws this game he's
doing okay yeah I see you guys are
saying in the chat that Danny and I are
supporting xi and that is not exactly
true we are supporting an equal score so
that we see more chess no I'm not
supporting either player I think that
this has been an exciting match I think
sometimes emotionally you get a little
bit attached to somebody when you see
them frustrated we knew LaVon was upset
about what happened earlier and I think
yeah you're right maybe maybe that leads
to a little bit of a human tendency to
kind of want him to fight back but nope
I honestly I honestly have no idea who I
would rather see place there gray
Carioca and I would rather see either
player play Sergey Aachen so not know
Rudi interest here but he did on wine
there LaVon found a way to kind of work
his way back he found a way to work his
way back and he actually won that pollen
somehow this still seems really weird
but that was impressive there I don't
know how black got got out of that that
was uh that was a bind but the news is
yeah I was gonna say I'm worried that
it's pinned but after Brooks e6 okay
that that fixes that problem
and now he can trade and go after the d4
pawn but look for an ebow to get some
chances against the king here this is an
exposed eighth-ranked and an exposed 7th
rank and that that's super dangerous in
fact here comes for takes c6 whoa what's
going on with rookie a check I have no
idea what's going on here
what is this there's rook d1 check
coming but LaVon has no time and Nebo is
using his time advantage smartly here he
knows that his chances are practical
only and that he has to find a way to
flag his opponent and he's trying to
play fast but LaVon barely held on got
out of that knee Poe is smartly not
gonna just resign here because he's got
to make his opponent has show some
technique & Windus because every second
off the total game clock right now
favors the Russian so this is um this is
going to be a very long game and with
that Deponia she is buying himself time
so there will be a couple of more games
but the last games the better for him
with his 2.0 any blunders okay so Jack
though that was funny I saw that coming
with LaVon kind of setting up the
seventh rank there so wowzers we're back
to a one game a one game match with that
win amazing then we have a stud look at
that we have a Dutch our first Dutch why
didn't he play the Staunton gambit LaVon
don't you know that's the best play you
four but ya know he's playing way too
solid here Aronian you got to play more
aggressive open I mean seriously ever if
a lot of time went off the clock here
and he doesn't get a win this is gonna
be a close position so we'll see we'll
see hit what happens in this one the
Dutch an interesting choice there by
nepo these guys have really started
mixing it up in the bullet portion tons
of different openings yeah we were
expecting this I already thought that
the three-minute portion would see some
of beat openings but now in the bullet
this is really happening look at that
the cheap one is marching I like this
then he castles
I like how we handle this opening in
apamea she just going forward so it's a
one-point advantage for anapana sheep
but there will be a couple of more games
until you see that time is running on
the screen and with bullet games this is
going very quick quintics be 7-eleven
has got a nice counter play I thought
that black was having a fine position
the bishop bug is having a fine position
I mean white still looking about those
pauses yeah it's going to be a mess
since the Queen is active he's down on
material but he's gonna have very active
pieces and after trading the d5 Bishop
which was a very important piece for
black the c6 poem will be big leak and
the rook and the Queen are already
attacking the c6 phone so I think now
Levin has good chances after Bishop c4
what's amazing is this one of the first
times we've ever seen whoa help how was
what oh that worked out Doug cuz the
rook was pinned and we are just was like
wow I know what I was gonna say is it I
agree that LaVon has chances here one of
the first times he's actually up on time
but okay now that's becoming much more
equal he just
oh he just blundered that pawn you could
see him kind of curse himself there I
saw I saw
LaVon sort of sort of whisper something
there inappropriate whisper something
inappropriate he was not happy with that
okay Depot guards the guards the sixth
rank he doesn't want there to be any
kind of mating net but watch this King
March from oh I thought he was gonna
play king of three and try to bring the
king up but no he does he goes for
something else oh he does go back to
this and after the sixth rank opens up
black has to be really careful about
ideas of this whoa what an interesting
movies
sacrificing his way through Oh violent
would have been beautiful yeah it's
takes brocade you wanna check it may
still be beautiful he's gonna get night
takes h6 and then and then he's got an
attack and the Knights coming around to
f6 and and things are getting uh he
could have even maybe just taken that
pawn Levon could have I think just
taking the pawn on f4 immediately but he
didn't he may regret that oh wow he wins
the exchange but isn't enough yeah isn't
enough to win I have no idea well he
still has a jeep or at least isn't
enough to win here nepo struggling to
hold he knows this is a huge game but
Levon only has a few seconds but he
buttered his Bishop rook d6 check on the
bishop but he says they're just missing
rook takes TC they're just missing
at this point both players tired the
brook was just the the bishop was just
hanging there
now he finds a way to get the room
behind the pawn but he blunders what in
the world
rookie saw the truth he's going on and
never was about the news on time I
thought that nip Lemieux just had no
time Wow maybe that was poetic justice
to have a draw there but I think Levon
really let one slip what a thriller this
game was winning in several moments
there Levon just winning on it on the
spot and then lets it slip into bonny
Poe holds on and now we see this coach
with the d6 set up which has more at
least gives more chances for black if
you play with d5 then it's usually if
white warms you can just go for a CRT
collateral position well these games are
so interesting with the different
blunders and I keep wanting to go back
to the previous game and I have a rule I
want to go back and be like what like
how did it do that like rook d6 Jack was
just winning the bishop for like three
moves right at least two moves it was
just over in one and we would have had a
tied match but nepo holds on and he's
really in the driver's seat now he's up
a game
five minutes to go if he wins this game
I think Nepal mija she's gonna move on
so and he and he is white and it's
currently I think he's I think he's
doing just fine in the Scotch so he
gobbles up the a5 pawn that makes sense
I think maybe I don't know now he did go
for it and that rugby one what is this
well yeah if he took on before the
knight was hanging on a5 so after the
Queen moves now I think we're gonna get
a trade probably the b-pawn will fall
for the a4 pawn at some point here LaVon
pausing to think about it but that's
been his weakness in today's match if
anything is in his time trouble Depot
leaning back in his and his gamers chair
there that's why they build those things
those things are built for comfort built
for long-term comfort like our stoles
Danny not like our stools not like our
backless stools as we suffer here 93 and
Rick takes a fight all right
serious disappearing from the board this
is weird
it's weird I don't know what's going on
now all the sudden White has a mating
attack things have switched it's got to
play g6 but his queen h6 like or queen
to c3 almost lights out here I mean
Queen to c3 how do you guard them mate I
don't think you can if Queen h6 Queen b2
is still possible at Queen c3 doesn't
know they France yeah if he finds it
okay f6 is the only move but super
dangerous for black the bond is barely
holding currently Aronian is barely
holding Queen to d6 only move right
finds a way to not get mated somehow and
not lose on time but Aronian is really
up against the wall here as time ticks
away if nepo can put this game away
you're you're basically looking at a
mathematical impossibility because of
the amount of time it takes
so if NEPA puts this game away as we
said I predict him to win this match
did he just blunder he did
LaVon blunders and resigns no he lost on
time what's what happened last night
time yeah the ball was down one time
yeah he just I forgot he had almost no
time yeah well I think that that that
might be I mean yes 960 game number
chess960 happens after regulation so
LaVon now has to win every game he has
to win this game and the chess960 game
to tie the match and so the match can
still be tied we are it is not over yet
but Aronian is up against the wall
currently having to win this game I
don't know that we've ever had such high
drama I mean this has been back and
forth been totally nuts
and not necessarily the highest quality
chest because it's been back and forth
we've had a lot of blunders under time
pressure but I you know nobody cares
about that it's been exciting yeah I
guess that's why we love Bullock chess
because there are so many mistakes and
it's super exciting you never know who
is going to win even if he is material
up he might lose and yeah this is such a
balanced match but now with two points
up I think pneumonia she is going to
advance and place order carjacking in
the next round actually they are good
friends and the three of them are good
friends we have seen some pictures from
Mike there's three of them hanging out
together in st. Louis chess championship
knee poker Aachen and Aronian yes yep
well yeah this one doesn't look this
well it looks totally unclear but I mean
I'm Roni would have to win this and they
would have to win as black in the
chess960 game which is what will happen
right after this even if even if Nippon
Rio she wins and sort of secures his
advancement there will still be a
chess960 game but obviously I think
everybody at this point even the biggest
of hominid Oishi fans have to be in
favor of the drama but look at this the
problem with this position for Aronian
is it's all there's like no attack right
you're pushing all these pieces but
where's the
actual attack here I don't know yeah and
with the Queen's coming off of the board
you can't really expect this to be good
news
yeah Bishop e7 will come and then he has
to back up the Queen which is just far
from desirable their time is ticking and
we are about to hit the end of
regulation which makes this game that's
what we already knew it was a literal
must-win for white or the match is over
and it looks like it looks like Aronian
is going down I mean he's worse in this
position the a2 pawn is a monster I
don't know what's happening on Bishop c3
at some point here but but it's going to
happen wait what what wasallam gave up
the piece what is okay he just counter
Bishop c3 winning the rook but was this
necessary yes suddenly things have
changed massively he's gonna get two
pieces for the rook I wonder why he
didn't just take a two and then takes c6
by the way but okay I thought that was a
better way to get the two pieces for the
rook transition but perhaps not okay but
LaVon can't take the draw he has to know
that he knows that he backs out he comes
up to g3 that's not his favorite thing
to do with a king but but he had to he
had no choice
Queen takes g4 was just winning for
white he had Queen 64 oh he can still
play queen g4 I don't know why not
playing Queen chief or trying to trade
Queens if you have the two pieces but
LaVon has found a way to work his way
back into this as long as he doesn't get
made it this is insane he's gonna lose
on time and can't lose on time he's like
he's on his way to losing on time I
don't think so I think he's just down on
time maybe maybe that's the case but it
seems that he's got problems right yeah
look at that
neato Queens trying to win nepo pulling
out all the bullet tricks and he does
and he wins on time oh my gosh wow it
it's over a nipple mission was over and
upon the air she wins today oh my gosh
that was insane that was dirty
honestly that was promoting that was
bullet tricks at their best Nepal Miyagi
complete but we've seen him do that a
couple times in the match today just
like take full advantage of his
opponents clock true it seems that he
really knows how to blame bullet chat so
is a very experienced bullet player
sometimes these moves for us they don't
really look just or fair but on the
other hand in bullet chess it happens
wow that was amazing that the promotion
was so dirty it was crazy that was all
right well obviously we have the we have
the chess960 portion still on the on the
agenda here as we as we look at look at
the score but as we yeah does not affect
who will advance but it will affect
their price money that Levon Aronian
receives for playing today right it does
affect price yeah but at this point I
think yeah he doesn't really care I
guess it's less less relevant to less
relevant to the players then then of
course moving on into pom neo she has
done just that
so as we check on the bracket here my
bracket is is probably not updated just
yet but no it is not but we know that
the pom neo she will be moving on as you
see there the 7c will be playing Sergey
Karjakin
amazing stuff we will obviously have
interviews right after right after this
and talk to the players we know that
it'll be upsetting for LaVon who I know
personally from talking to him while I
was in st. Louis there for a couple of
days really wanted to really wanted to
move on after losing a super close match
last year to Sascha crook but he goes
down again in a super close match to the
pom Miyoshi a match that you know he
really seemed to play the better chess
right but as far as the better online
chess skills and the blitz skills when
it really mattered most and
time-management nepo was better today
anna yeah he was and he he really played
fast chess from the very beginning even
if it was not perfect quality but in
blitz you can't really be perfect and
maybe that was
but LaVon was missing that he wanted to
play - well he displayed better than
upon machine those games but then his
time usage was not ideal at all and he
did end up winning the chess960 game
amazing stuff if he had won that game
without losing on time he probably would
be either that would have been tying the
match right there a pretty amazing
attack right there but we didn't focus a
lot on it but fans should definitely
check out that game but let's see if we
have the players here if they're able to
take a few moments to talk with us here
and and we will welcome welcome back
both LaVon and a young if if you guys
can hear us let us know yeah I can yep
all right well first of all super
exciting match we know it was just
discipline I don't know if anybody has
any headphones I wonder whose connection
that is but LaVon I know is is super
disappointing obviously with what
happened there with the the
disconnection with the the poor moment
of internet there so obviously super
disappointing to see the match go down
that way but how did you feel overall
about your play and and it seemed like
you were down on time kind of probably
more than you would like that a few of
these games didn't go your way because
of the time scrambled would you say
that's a fair a fair assessment of how
some of those games I think I was
playing pretty well up to a point when
you guys forfeited me and then it went
down worse from there I mean I I was
already not really enjoying myself so
but a twist in the end of the day well
we are was terrible and unfortunately
that's how the online rules are set up
to work but either way it's
disappointing we thank you for the hard
for unmatched yawn you you ended up
winning a super close match you seemed
just you knew what you were doing in the
time scramble there obviously did you
know how close the match was when you
played that promotion trick and and and
kind of beat LaVon on time there in that
last game well I mean I I saw this
course and I believe I was Suffolk bused
to it but moments are I should I mean it
was better than you know
Nicole score so I mean if all the match
was very very tough I mean especially
because of the jet lag but I mean okay
we traveled from st. Louis to Mitch
muscular energy we want to travel by one
you know one fight so we were in
absolutely same conditions and I mean of
course it's pity that so much it was
decided in some you know flagging battle
but I mean and also here it's a
unit 11 had some troubles for instrument
because I mean it was I score at that
moment I belief and you know this really
[Music]
it was really bad I mean for you know a
match of the rolls it wasn't balanced
but I mean 11 is a great fight friend I
know of course I believe it was far from
Raskin during its which I mean you know
all the circumstances circumstances
phone absolutely energy you've any other
questions
sure but I think I hear myself as well I
don't know if 11 I was going to ask you
I know that you must be very
disappointed by this match but 2017 has
been such a great here for you you've
been every super tournament that you
participate in and I heard that on the
30th of September it's going to be yet
another glorious event for you and you
tell us about that
well we're gonna have a wedding ceremony
in the era that I I think it's not a
secret and I really believe that 2017
has been a year of Leven Aronian we have
seen you winning every important super
tournament and we wish you the best of
luck for the World Cup as well as well
to you young who you will go to Tbilisi
as well I did and to you I wanted to ask
about eSports
since you follow dota 2 you play
yourself I believe in her
stone how do you see those conditions
they have a huge number of viewership
huge price phones and what dannion the
chat that come team is trying to do now
with the speech as championship is a
similar idea to make chess and eSport do
you see that chess could go in this
direction more tournaments could follow
yeah well anyway chase will you know
just remains chance that's clear
exciting is hard stone is that what
you're saying what are you saying chess
isn't as exciting as hearthstone oh man
I some different stuff because I'm huge
I just bet in hearthstone you know maybe
I made in just two but I mean at this
time if we compare I'm well and I think
it's clear which it's a it's a good idea
you know to stream chess online like to
each twitch TV aired on YouTube and so
on and so and so on and well I don't
believe we can quickly reach you know
the same number of viewers here like the
same so it was like five minutes or even
ten millions watching the finals of dota
2 international you know two weeks ago
and I mean okay I believe we would be
happy we can find a you know at least 1
million but I mean we should who should
I should work we have some work to do
right well I wanted to say again I mean
we had a few more specific chess
questions too but overall this was such
a kind of an emotional roller coaster
and in such a close match I yeah it was
nothing connected to chess I believer
yeah I think it's for me after you know
half an hour I was completely down and I
just couldn't see what's going on yeah
well we appreciate both you guys we know
it's late there and obviously the vol
and we know this was not the way we
wanted this match to go and we
appreciate you being being being the
gentleman and his sticking around so
we're sorry about that but you know what
this was a super hard fought match you
guys both it was you guys had the fans
on the edge of their seat the Chester
AMA was real and nepo congratulations on
moving on to the next round you will be
facing your country
Sergei Kuryakin in round two should be
exciting right how do you think you
stack up against Sergei in a blitz match
like this well I have no idea so depends
on when would it be hold white in
October or something I thought of time
to be before but I mean it once again it
will be very it's made but still I
believe the Czech have good to do so you
know this pairings a good one of the
most strong strongest players in beliefs
of a role but you know that one just
proved it brilliantly you know a few
days ago in st. Louis so I wasn't really
happy for my parent in the first round
and you know the second round pairing is
not really any better well I try to do
my best right
well it only gets tougher from here yep
as you said congratulations though as
you will face rueake and LaVon as well
again thank you so much for doing this
and thank you both for for a great post
post match interview and hope to have
you next year Levon and
nepo congratulations in the next round
and and we will we will see you in
October thank you see ya